maintaining
already
of course
three two one
[Music]
it's hard to express how excited all of
us at Bethesda are to be here with you
today we're so grateful you're spending
the time and we know you've waited a
long time to finally see Starfield it's
easily our most ambitious game ever like
our previous games it's an epic
role-playing game where you get to be
who you want and go where you want but
this time you'll be exploring space so
let's Jump Right In This is early in the
game as you arrive on the mysterious
moon of Crete
thank you
[Music]
according to the scanners the abandoned
research facility is in this direction
thank you
foreign
[Music]
it would appear that pirates of the
Crimson Fleet are using the facility
foreign
[Music]
come on
you're gonna pay for that
after some initial encounters you're
invited to join constellation who in the
future of the game is set in are the
last group of Space Explorers to meet
them you'll head to the capital city of
New Atlantis
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to Constellation we have a lot
to talk about
we're all here
as we're committed
[Music]
what's out there
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for
as to what they are what they're
building
[Music]
you will be part of solving that puzzle
now
dug up the artifact right that means you
saw it the Visions
the artifact you found appears to be one
of many scattered across the Galaxy if
we can find more we can unlock their
secrets beautiful isn't it Man Who Sold
me this told me that it spoke to him of
course the settle systems is full of
groups with other priorities
[Applause]
agree to work for UC sister together we
take down this Cutthroat Pirates
we're not just here to shoot the bad
guys we're peacekeepers we project the
people to the Freestar Collective when
you sign up with the Crimson Fleet thing
no one quits the only way out
is death the path ahead may be dangerous
but we are not stopping
most dusties don't even make it this far
Ed
will change
[Music]
forever
that gives you a look at the stories in
Starfield But ultimately it's not our
story it's the story you create by who
you are and the choices you make and
that starts with character creation
[Music]
it's our most flexible yet
you can customize all the elements of
how you look
[Music]
you'll pick a background that gives you
three starting skills
[Music]
it says here you spend some time as a
diplomat having a way with words might
prove useful there are optional traits
and these come with unique advantages
and disadvantages
but it's not just in how you can look
and how your character plays and
develops
[Music]
the skill system combines the best from
our previous games and you can unlock
new skills as you level up and then you
rank those skills up by using them and
completing challenges
and there's deep crafting systems from
running research projects with resources
you find
to crafting weapon mods and needed to
survive
[Music]
and you can build your own outposts
these act as a home away from home for
survival and resource generation
you can choose where and how to build
each one and you can hire characters you
meet to keep it up and running
but that's not all
you can even build your own spaceships
[Music]
you can choose crew members
and yes you can completely customize the
look and layout
there's loads of different modules ship
manufacturers and more
[Music]
we just absolutely love this
it's not just how the ship looks it's
how it performs from engines to Shields
to weapon systems because yes you can
fly it
monsters posted
[Music]
thank you
we can't wait for all of you to
experience the game thanks again for
being with us today and thanks for all
the support you've given us over the
decades especially on this game it's
been an incredible journey for us making
it but we know that's really only the
beginning for it's when all of you play
it that the real Journey Begins
and you may be wondering just how big is
this game
so we thought we'd take one last moment
and show you
let's take a look at one of our planets
jemisin
you can land in new Atlantis but you can
also land and explore
anywhere on the planet
and it's not just this planet it's all
the planets in the system
from Barren but resource heavy ice balls
it's a Goldilocks planets with life
and not just this system
but over a hundred systems over one
thousand planets all open for you to
explore
we can't wait to see what you find
[Music]
foreign
on behalf of hexworks Welcome to the
Lords of the Fallen gameplay showcase
today we're taking a closer look at our
all-new dark fantasy action RPG arriving
this October on PC PS5 and Xbox series
xns
foreign
spiritual successor to the original 2014
release it acts as a full reboot for the
franchise taking place in a vast
interconnected world over a thousand
years later
featuring colossal boss battles fast
challenging combat and deep immersive
storytelling players will journey across
two parallel Realms in this expansive
RPG experience the world of the living
Axiom and the world of the Dead
Umbro with each featuring its own unique
Pathways characters enemies and of
course Treasures
and while Axiom presents its own
challenges Untold Horrors await in its
nightmarish counterpart
thanks to the umbral lamp players can
enter this flightless world at any time
in one of two ways when slain by the
foes of Axiom at which point you'll
resurrect in the same location albeit in
umbral
or by performing The umbral Rift and
willingly sacrificing one of your two
lives
but the lamp holds yet more power
granting the ability to Flay the soul
from an enemy for some high damage
attacks and even manipulate the very
environment of the umbral world
however the longer you spend in this
wraith-ridden plane the greater number
of spectral Terrors that will hunt you
down
as harrowing as the hellions of
umbrellar they pale in comparison to the
game's brutal boss battles
towering above the ever burning city of
kalrath the Garden can't you in
monstrosity doesn't take kindly to
would-be adventurers a demonic presence
within ready to devour any and all
within sight
in merciless torturer prepared to carry
out any atrocity in the name of his
faith tankrid master of castigations is
The Devout chaplain of the hallowed
Sentinels though beneath the pies fail
his very own flesh conceals a truth most
powerful
when Harrow or Darva ventured into the
deepest depths of this world to thwart
the undead Rising what she discovered
was so utterly horrific that she
renounced her former life and commitment
to a far darker oath
pre-order Lords of the Fallen now and
prepare to unleash the darkness on
Friday the 13th of October
[Music]
thank you
laughs
[Music]
allow me to reproduce myself my name is
number one supplier
my name is
[Music]
trying to make some change
the game
[Music]
all right
hey hey
[Music]
it's sometimes difficult to reconcile
that Diablo 3 is over a decade old its
release was polarizing for a number of
reasons but its evolving formula of
action role-playing endured enjoying a
Resurgence with its post-launch
expansion that carried through years of
ongoing seasonal updates it shouldn't
come as a surprise then that each of
those years helped inform the design of
Diablo 4 a game which confidently
delivers gameplay that has been carried
forward and refined from Diablo 2 and 3.
while also establishing a strong
foundation for the franchise's future
foreign
games have always contained stories for
their single player campaigns but you'd
be forgiven for thinking of past
storylines as merely contextualization
for the game's primary focus dungeon
crawling that's where Diablo 4 makes one
of its most striking changes it not only
takes its story far more seriously but
it tells one that's far more engrossing
than ever before as a traveling Wanderer
you come across a small town of villages
on a snow-capped mountain range looking
for some Aid after killing some
creatures and returning you're welcomed
as a hero and given food and shelter
only for the villagers to try and use
you in a ritual sacrifice to Lilith
co-creator of sanctuary and recently
resurrected antagonists of this tale
this encounter links you to Lilith
driving you forward on a quest to stop
her plan of amassing an army for her own
nefarious purposes
by mother's blood
by mother's body
so shall you witness her glory
before you die
much of that sounds like standard Diablo
Fair there's a big bad demon and you're
the only one who can stop it but Diablo
4 makes intelligent use of Lilith
layering her motivation slowly to the
point where you can't help but consider
her side of the argument she's not
driven solely by a Lust For Destruction
instead she's grieving with the place
she once created to escape the endless
cycle of War Between Heaven and Hell now
being used as a staging ground to
continue it she's an antagonist that has
been slighted by those she trusted at
every turn and while her means of
exacting Justice provide the reason for
your entire crusade in the first place
it's surprising and equally welcome when
Diablo 4 forces you to slow down and
consider the true goal of your struggle
not just any demon
the daughter of hatred the mother of
sanctuary the trop of the Soul Survivor
has been tried and tested in Diablo for
years and Diablo 4 doesn't completely
change that instead it puts a much
larger emphasis on companions than ever
before with most acts centered around a
new party member rather than a demon
you're eventually hunting down an early
standout is Vigo a prideful Knight who
is forced to endure a conscious ruining
loss after a single selfish action it's
not just vigo's remorse that is
heart-wrenchingly conveyed but also the
horrors of his eventual Redemption
leading to one of the more powerful
character moments in the entire game
vigo's story is a teaser for many
similar arcs that follow all of which do
a great job of providing a cause for
your character to join your fight while
also contextualizing their motivations
to continue or abstain from the enduring
conflict this applies to most of the
Allies you recruit in your fight against
the lift Each of which has their own
motivations that feel faithful to their
respective Journeys it's a level of care
I can't recall being given to many past
Diablo Companions and Diablo 4 certainly
makes far more liberal use of them
through the campaign to make them feel
purposeful bringing together this ragtag
group takes place over Diablo 4's
extensive sex acts some of which you can
tackle in different orders previous
Diablo titles had each Act accompanied
by a change in Locale but in Diablo 4 it
only takes a few moments before you're
given free reign to explore its
intimidatingly large interconnected map
here you can transition from frigid
mountaintops to desolate deserts in just
a matter of minutes with the
transitional areas doing a good job of
masking an otherwise jarring change
having a static layout that you can
learn and get comfortable with induced
Exploration with a greater sense of
wonder than previous hubs which were
often filled with enemies to kill before
diving into the next dungeon the
geography also gives towns and larger
cities a sense of place on a bigger map
each distinct area is shown off of a
great amount of visual detail with
Diablo 4 incorporating a delightfully
Macabre style that is befitting of its
violent story it's not trying to overly
correct some of the criticisms laid on
Diablo 3 either with pops of color used
Tastefully to highlight areas of Hope
and kinship that contrast against the
broader Strokes of dread and fear
painting the rest of the landscape
things don't always hold up when the
camera Zooms in to give conversations a
cinematic feel as a degradation in
detail on character models and
environments is a little more
discernible regardless it's still a
striking presentation that looks
incredible in motion while also keeping
information clear enough to read when
fights get chaotic
and no one else
the moment-to-moment action Diablo 4 is
one of its strongest traits which is for
the best given how genre defining the
series has been over the years there's
an argument to be made that Diablo 3
went too far in the direction of
simplification and that's exactly where
Diablo 4 course corrects in smart ways
you're still limited to a total of six
Active abilities at a time four on your
Hotbar and two on each Mouse button for
those on PC but how you construct your
build is no longer linear instead each
new level lets you invest a point in a
branching skill tree with each of his
core notes branching further out into
new abilities and Associate passive
perks you need to invest a certain
number of total points that continue
unlocking each of these nodes so you
will have to think carefully about
abilities and how they serve your
greater build it's a system that allows
for a lot of flexibility letting you
experiment with focusing on one specific
ability as the foundation of your build
or dabbling with ways to combine two
entirely different paths such as
empowering your summon skeletons while
also firing off loads of blood infused
magic as a necromancer
foreign
[Applause]
experimentation is further encouraged by
Diablo 4's low cost to respect and
unlimited chances to do so unlike the
more punishing approach of end Diablo 2
you can completely redefine your build
at any time for a small fee of in-game
gold approaching your skill tree with a
different idea or mindset or just making
some small changes to adjust for a
difficult fight this freedom is
empowering in a similar way to that of
Diablo 3's fluid build system but it
still requires you to engage
meaningfully with synergies to make your
builds viable it feels like the
culmination of all the ways previous
games in the series have allowed you to
play while catering to as many play
stars as possible but without many of
the critical compromises from the last
time out the cost for respect does
naturally increase the higher your level
but I never got to a point where I felt
it was too expensive in relation to the
amount of gold I was earning at the time
thanks to this system I felt free to
continually change up my approach to my
Necromancer I started with a combination
of skeleton summoning Shadow damaging
attacks and some blood spells for
survivability The Necromancer is unique
I believe lets me either summon minions
from corpses or sacrifice the ability
entirely for Passive advantage Ages
which led me to realize that I could
theoretically play a necromancer
entirely as a pseudo-mage with Blood and
Bone abilities after some taxing boss
battles I decided to go all in on a
summoning build that accentuated the
abilities of my skeleton soldiers Mages
and large hulking Golem Each of which
had three different variations that
could combine to find the perfect
Synergy it was consistently satisfying
to find a build that worked for a couple
of hours and then completely change it
either through necessity or curiosity
seeing small decisions manifest as big
changes in terms of overall viability
gives me faith that each class is going
to be picked apart for various
approaches that maximize elements of
different play Styles while the skill
tree is where you will ultimately
establish the basis of your build
aspects of power or a new facet of the
role-playing formula that allows you to
hone it these collectible skills so to
speak can be combined with rare pieces
of gear to turn them into custom
legendary items imbued with the exact
ability that complements the build
you're constructing this alleviates some
of the headaches associated with
grinding out dungeons in the hopes of a
particularly legendary piece of gear
dropping while also providing a new
Avenue of options for build construction
that isn't to say it diminishes the rush
of a big legendary drop though Legendary
Weapons can often feature the same
abilities as aspects do but will
regularly have better percentage roles
on their effectiveness making them the
ideal path to the most optimal late game
build still
aspects of Power are obtained by
clearing the many dungeons sprawl around
the map Each of which feature their own
multi-stage objective to complete some
are as simple as killing enemies and
depositing their souls to progress
further While others require you to hunt
down a specific foe in search of a key
that lets you reach lower levels of the
dungeon each of these concludes with a
boss fight which for the most part are
less interesting than those found in the
main story dungeons bosses throughout
the story are multi-layered bouts with
shifting enemy attacks that can
completely change the landscape you're
fighting in forcing you to consistently
think about positioning and when the
best moment for an attack is bosses in
these more common dungeons lack that
sense of complexity and I often found
mascular and warriors completely
overwhelming many of them to the point
where many of the bosses would just
stand in place and attack until dead
thank you
given the sheer number of dungeons on
offer it might not have been possible to
retain the same level of tension across
every boss encounter but when you're
bouncing between several of these as you
grab aspects of power throughout your
campaign it's difficult not to notice
the stark contrast and quality between
the two as with any Diablo title Diablo
4 is nowhere near complete once you've
rolled credits on the campaign
voltaire's return to incentivize you to
go through everything again with a high
degree of difficulty but also more
rewards to reap it's welcome that Diablo
4 retains the option that allows you to
jump into more challenging World tiers
from the very start this time preventing
a potentially frustrating first
playthrough devoid of any meaningful
challenge outside of increasing world
here the map becomes littered with
additional side activities that join
regular side quests rotating open mode
Dynamic quests similar to the Patrols in
Destiny 2 and strongholds strongholds
are extremely hostile areas that are
densely populated with enemies usually a
level or two higher than you providing a
larger challenge to overcome than
regular groups or foes around the open
world minor objectives also make this
feel like a smaller scale open-air
dungeon with new waypoints and Merchants
usually on locked once you've read the
area of the threat
foreign
larger scale World boss fights that are
best tackled with numerous other players
you will find in the open world are also
available although no multiplayer
features were available during the
review period finally Whispers of the
Dead encapsulate time bounties that pop
up throughout the world with each one
rewarding you with an additional
currency that can be turned in for
caches of gems weapons and More Night
messages which can be obtained through
completing Whispers of the Dead quests
can be used to unlock additional
nightmare dungeons these add new
modifiers to existing dungeons around
the map that can do anything from change
the type of enemies you encounter to
Rolling new random abilities they might
have at their disposal with the Allure
of even rarer loot drops enticing you to
run them over and over again
there's a familiar but equally expensive
framework in place already in Diablo 4
that should satiate you across multiple
playthroughs with plans already detailed
by a blizzard to expand on this through
seasons of new content similar to that
of Diablo 3. now
true work begins Diablo 4 at this time
cannot Escape comparison to the past of
the franchise it belongs to but it's
thankfully a game that has been crafted
with a strong awareness of what made
each one either revered or reviled it
represents a measured approach to
combining the many elements from
previous entries that worked into a
system that feels like the new standard
Bearer for Action role-playing coupled
with a new Benchmark for storytelling in
the franchise and a solid narrative
foundation for any potential new
adventures it's easy to see a Diablo 4
as something I'll regularly check out
for a long time to come
thank you
[Music]
it unlocks our path to the Future
a future made possible because of the
price you paid
[Music]
your sacrifice
will not have been in vain
[Music]
We Begin by hearing an old wise sounding
voice
when we see a quiet peaceful setting
this will make our game seem big and
important now something must break the
serenity
will this creature be in the game
say goodbye to it forever
suddenly and for no reason
[Music]
these pointless slow motion shots make
everything you seem cool and should
bolster pre-sale numbers
that Noah sound can mean only one thing
we must gaze over an epic shot of a
world and there should be lens flares
now we see our heroes but only the
silhouette because the developers
haven't finished the design I won't
finish the story all finished any
gameplay that's actually ready to show
in fact the only thing they have
finished
[Music]
is the title
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
last question Dr dalan are you sure the
perimeter surrounding the zone is really
enough if a powerful emission were to
occur we would listen The Zone has
remained stable for years besides we
didn't establish the most advanced
institution in human history without
first guaranteeing its safety as the
head of the scientific Institute for
research of the Chernobyl area or a
circle for short I believe the Wonders
that we will bring to the world far
outweigh the potential risks how big are
these risks exactly
the Zone reveals A Whole New World
stick with the old one fearing change
tell me
do you want our descendants to remember
us as cowards or as those who dare to
venture forwards to a new better
Humanity
injured were evacuated I remind our
listeners that a similar incident
happened in our region quite recently
ruining homes and livelihoods
thank you
forever City officials urge people to
stay calm assuring them the situation is
totally understandable
[Music]
foreign
so this is usually the bit where I take
a bunch of stuff out of the locker and
there's like a really cool Montage but I
have nothing to take out because we're
talking about Game Pass which is
entirely digital
and also it has been around for six
years
it is the service that has become
synonymous with the phrase the greatest
deal in gaming and rightfully so it has
had a tremendous impact on the way many
of us play games
me included no really it has
it has changed me over the years of
being a Game Pass subscriber my
relationship with games how I buy them
play them and what console I choose to
play them on has been dramatically
altered honestly it's kind of debatable
whether or not that's a good or a bad
thing because I think it's a little bit
of both in fact the whole thing has got
me asking is Game Pass changing how I or
how we all value games
[Music]
when I take a step back and reflect on
the past six years my thoughts are
usually always it's been great I've
never been this versed in games before I
get to try things I otherwise wouldn't
and yada yada yada and that is all true
but there's another side to this and no
two games better illustrate my
relationship with Game Pass than
ghostwire Tokyo and Hi-Fi rush and by
the way both of those games are actually
by the exact same developer Tango
Gameworks which is completely
coincidental really let's start with
ghostwire Tokyo when ghostwire Tokyo was
revealed it was showcased as a
PlayStation exclusive it had the devs
Behind The Evil Within it was a new IP
it was spooky paranormal and Fantastical
it seemed by all accounts like a Kurt
game however around the same time it was
revealed Microsoft announced its
acquisition of Tango's parent company
Bethesda softworks which meant its days
as a PS5 exclusive or inevitably
numbered it was only a man out of time
until it made its way on to Game Pass so
despite my interest in the game I held
off I didn't buy it in the hopes that it
would eventually come to the
subscription service as a result a game
that I was actually pretty excited for
was shoved to the back of my mind until
a year later when it did indeed come to
Game Pass and oh yes that was a
pre-install all right now on the high
five Rush
during an Xbox showcase earlier this
year Tango Gameworks revealed an all-new
hyper-stylized cartoonishly over-the-top
Rhythm action game it looked really cool
and then out of nowhere like a Nintendo
Direct mic drop we're happy to tell you
that you can play Hi-Fi Rush tonight
that made it suddenly even cooler the
results swept through headlines and blew
up my Twitter feed an absolute slam dunk
of a surprise and yeah I instantly
installed it but here's the thing if
Hi-Fi Rush had just launched as a
regular game at a regular price without
the support of Game Pass I know I would
have most likely passed on it nothing
against it like at all I just know that
if I had to vote with my dollars I
probably would have put those dollars
somewhere else maybe even ghostwire
Tokyo but because it launched on Game
Pass a service that I browse almost
every single day I had nothing to lose
but to give it a shot and you know what
it's pretty good and you know what I
didn't think was very good ghostwire
Tokyo
let that sinking for a second
oh and also another important point that
involves both those games is that I
haven't finished either one of them
and I likely won't so what do I do with
this realization on one hand there was a
game I wanted waited and stalled it
played it for a few hours and decided it
wasn't for me but on the other hand was
a game I wouldn't have played but
because it was available to me I did and
end up enjoying it but I still did not
finish it when I realized this it had me
starting to look a little closer at my
overall habits with the greatest deal in
gaming some of my favorite games are on
Game Pass new and old ones some of which
are from a pre-game pass world Grim
Fandango Paradise killer 999 the Yakuza
series While others I got to play
because of Game Pass Norco and mortality
hellblade gun grave Gore but the thing
is I realized while I was scrolling
through all the games on Game Pass
there's really only a handful and then
some that I've actually seen to the end
otherwise there is a graveyard of
Unfinished games on my hard drive
Proteus a scorn tunic signalus The
Pedestrian pentiment and of course Hi-Fi
rush and ghost wire Tokyo or how about
the games I installed and just haven't
even touched like Somerville Ninja
Gaiden and The Artful Escape yeah I
don't really feel great about it also I
realized that like half these games that
like I have installed or from Game Pass
aren't actually even on Game Pass
anymore that's how long it's
you need to get around to some of these
games are just completely abandon them
for you know reasons of course I'm a
strong believer in the mentality that if
you don't want to finish a book
then you shouldn't and similar to books
games require a little more engagement
from you compared to something say like
movies or TV shows and to me it becomes
more about your time and attention as
the measurement of value rather than the
actual dollar amount when I think about
my time with ghostwire Tokyo or even
HiFi Rush would I have spent more time
with them maybe even viewed them
differently if I had actually purchased
them I honestly don't know but it's
enough to unravel my entire perception
of why I buy and play what I do versus
what I don't oh and speaking of when I
actually do buy a game I'm most likely
buying it on Xbox because it has become
my primary console and I owe that to
Game Pass
which is actually maybe really the point
here if I'm measuring success in my time
then well Xbox has won it because
regardless of whether or not I'm playing
a game on Game Pass or not I'm still
turning my Xbox on every day more than
any of the other consoles which was not
the case a few years back in fact I made
an entire video about that and how my
perception of Microsoft has changed to
say the least I wasn't even an Xbox user
until Game Pass came along that's game
passes crowning achievement over the
past six years getting people to talk
about Xbox and spend time on its
consoles and in the process it has
raised the bar for what will motivate me
to actually spend money on a game it
makes me think about the games I haven't
played or have not bought in hopes that
they will come to a service like Game
Pass games like the Callisto protocol
like ghostwire Tokyo there's a lot going
for the callista protocol that had me
interested I love survival horror it was
deemed as a dead space spiritual
successor despite Dead Space remake
releasing only a month later and yet I
wasn't entirely sold on it you might
assume that it's because of the review
scores but it wasn't I actually have an
entire video about that that you should
consider watching it was that it didn't
seem interesting or compelling enough it
just had me curious at best which to me
is the quintessential sign of a I'll
just wait for Game Pass sort of game
even just saying that makes it feel like
I'm devaluing the games that do launch
the game pass which is not the case at
all this is just how my brain works now
so much so that if the callista protocol
was on PlayStation's game catalog Sony's
answer to Game Pass then maybe just
maybe I'd actually consider subscribing
to a whole other service just to play it
and that but in of itself is a messed up
situation for me to unpack that I
wouldn't consider playing a game that I
was interested in unless it was a part
of a subscription service like Game Pass
I would rather pay 15 extra a month to
play a game that on paper takes all of
my boxes rather than just Fork up
seventy dollars for a game that I may
even potentially love I at least know
that I'm not the only one that shifted
in some sort of way because of Game Pass
after all PlayStation did make the game
catalog the exact same model as Game
Pass and has been using it as a means to
Showcase some cool games like Humanity
or even stray as Day One releases for
the service I Still Love Game Pass and
I'm still gonna use it as a means to
dabble and experiment and try things
because that is what I'm paying for one
way or another it demonstrates that we
are living in a Host Game Pass world at
the moment and I'm having a hard time
imagining a pivot back
you know what
I'm buying the cluster protocol
foreign
[Music]
with our swords we will Forge new
stories to strike the gods that haunt us
you might see me as weak
but I will show you what lies behind my
eyes
are suffering
soothe our scars of grief and break
their Siege of our minds you
use gods
we will show you what lies behind their
eyes
listen listen
it's coming
it knows our
own how does it know to risk your own
life for what you believe is your
sacrifice to make
you can lead others to death
brings a different kind of Burden
one that's senower
would have to learn
remember
I don't know
dad is coming
can you smell that fear
look at the bones
look at the bones that's going to be you
[Music]
those whose eyes are clouded by fear of
opposed by the ghosts that haunt them
senua saw that to win the war we must
break this Siege
break it with an unshakable truth
break it
with an impossible feat
get ready
get ready firstly emailed down the fire
yes yes
no go yes
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Eric Harris
time
do it
take me
me it wants to kill
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
she's dead
[Music]
I know you he needs you
3506 has learned lessons from the
content Bear release of its predecessor
and offers a variety of significant
features and modes right out of the gate
it's a robust fighting game that is a
premier quality a return to form for the
franchise that welcomes both new
Fighters and seasoned Pros
356 splits this content into three hubs
fighting ground which most closely
emulates the classic street fight
experience battle Hub where players can
congregate and challenge each other to
compete in tournaments and World Tour
which is a sprawling story mode with an
open world and RPG hooks each gameplay
format centers on the classic Street
Fighter style of 2D fighting gameplay
and that excellent core experience is
what drives everything
mechanically Street Fighter 6 doesn't
fall far from previous games in the
series you have multiple normal attacks
special attacks super arts and movement
techniques specifically designed for
each of the roster's 18 characters what
distinguishes street fighter 6 from
previous iterations are the core
Universal mechanics shared by all
characters these Universal mechanics are
also where much of street fighters
gameplay depth is the drive system is
356's new Universal battle mechanic and
I'm amazed at how much it adds despite
being simple to grasp by pressing the
two medium attack buttons I can Parry an
attack using Drive power free or with
Drive rush I can immediately Dash
forward out of it for a burst of speed
that can catch opponents off guard or
introduce new combo sequences
yeah
functionally players that are
experienced with Street Fighter 4's
Focus attack Dash cancel all kill we
gears Roman cancels will feel right at
home by pressing both heavy attacks I
can initiate a drive impact that can
stagger an opponent and leave them open
ensuring that overly defensive players
can be opened up if an opponent is
backed into a corner Landing this will
make him Bounce Off the Wall adding a
variety of other strategic
considerations and opportunities Drive
reversals meanwhile allow me to block an
attack and counter with a move that
while not very damaging will help Escape
tricky spots and finally overdrive lets
me power up special attacks like the EX
system of all
these aren't unlimited however as each
move uses up part of the drive gauge
just below the health bar and a fighter
can burn out which slows their movement
speed and makes certain offensive and
defensive moves inaccessible for a
period the Strategic implications of
this system cannot be overstated as
these new tools do wonders for the
overall fighting drive impact in
particular can swing the tide of the
battle in an instant as catching an
unsuspecting opponent with one will
allow you to put a hurting on them
keeping these tools in front of your
mind is key to Victory and luckily it's
not an overwhelming amount to recall one
of the major criticisms leveled at 355
was the rigidity of battles with some
going so far as to call it turn based
however these new mechanics make stream
fighter 6 feel more fluid
okay
no matter how simple Street Fighters can
seem novice players are going to feel
some trepidation when stepping into the
ring for the first time the game is
ready for you though as Capcom has
implemented a new modern control scheme
that makes controlling Fighters more
like Super Smash Bros than a traditional
Street Fighter this gives new players a
foundation from which to learn but that
growth does have a ceiling if you decide
to transition to the classic control
scheme players will need to learn the
manual input controls that have been
used since Street Fighter 2. the easiest
place to learn 356 either in modern or
classic Styles is in fighting ground
which is a traditional 3-5 experience
this is where you'll find familiar modes
like arcade mode online ranked and
Casual matches and offline versus modes
this section's shining feature however
is its practice area which houses some
of the best in-game tutorials the series
has ever had practice mode has the
classic freeform training mode fans
expect but also holds full tutorials for
the game's core systems as well as
character guides and combo trials for
all 18 characters on the roster these
character guides are a deep dive into
what makes each fight a tick as it
explains not only their special moves
but also the best situations in which to
use them fighting ground also lets you
Tinker with in-game commentators one of
the more balihood features of Street
Fighter 6.
oh
no where's the driver while hearing
tasty Steve and WWE Zelena Vega in an
official Street Fighter game is super
cool the excitement those commentators
generate during an actual tournament
isn't ever captured here those
experiences are fueled by genuine
off-the-cuff reactions to the action on
the screen and in the arena while those
same voices sound like they're reading
situations from a script here which of
course is exactly what they are doing
Thrills to get around their defense if
you're looking for a less traditional
Street Fighter experience then what's
offered in fighting ground it's time to
take a world tour this is a massive
story mode with multiple chapters that
unfolds across the entire world the main
Hub is Metro city of final fight Fame
and it's tough with things to do and
references for long-time Capcom fighting
fans to find the rest of the mode is
broken up into smaller locations based
on stages from the core game these are
one of locales you'll visit sparingly so
they're not as big as Metro City but
they all still have a charm to them the
story being told in World Tour doesn't
live up to the standard set by fighting
games like Tekken 7 and more combat 11.
however everything happening around the
story makes up for it in a big way walto
is essentially a street fighter RPG
where the fighting mechanics servers the
battle system and it is very silly fun
walking through the streets of Metro
City I can challenge virtually anyone I
want to a fight be they a food truck
attendant an old lady going to the store
or a young Troublemaker getting up to no
good with every victory in my avatar
gains experience and levels up both
their core stats and the fighting styles
I'm using at the time this challenge
anyone mechanic is also technically
impressive as it really does let players
challenge anyone the game seamlessly
goes from challenging a passerby into a
fight and then returning to the free
realm without loading the stage is
whatever we were standing in front of at
that moment there is a noticeable dip in
frame rate when fighting in World Tour
and the visual quality of the stages and
random Fighters is nowhere near as good
looking as Ryu fighting Ken on a
carefully crafted stage but I didn't
focus on them much as I was too busy
enjoying the silliness of fighting every
Metro City Denizen that passed me by or
using money to to buy a hat that somehow
improves my kicking power leveling up
fighting styles is the other major
customization option and growth path
your Avatar's move set is in your hands
and as you progress through the story of
Walter you meet the 18 masters of the
world aka the playable roster of Street
Fighter characters after earning their
respect through Mission completion or
even a one-on-one fight your avatar will
be enrolled as a student and given
access to that character's moveset
you'll pick a core move set for normals
but then you can pick and choose which
special moves you want your character to
use at one point my avatar used DJ's
rolling sober blank as Blanca ball
chunley spinning bird kick and Ken
troyukin that versatility and ability to
create your own fighter down to the
moveset is something new for the
franchise and a core part of what makes
World Tour fun using a fight stick to
control the Avatar in this mode is rough
the camera controls do not translate to
a controller with only one stick so
getting around the city can be
cumbersome the game does offer a
solution though it's not an elegant one
you can activate your fight stick as
Player 1 and your controller as player 2
and then switch between the two
depending on if you're moving around
Metro City or fighting someone while
this does mean extra space is needed for
two controls at once I appreciate the
convenience of easily switching every
time I want to use it your avatar also
takes center stage in the battle Hub
which is the final section of Street
Fighter 6's experience this is basically
a middle ground between World Tour and
fighting ground where players bring
their avatars into a massive Dome lined
with arcade cabinets you can sit down at
a cabinet and wait for a challenger
while training or you can join a queue
of players already seated the digital
equivalent of putting a quarter down on
a machine through fighter 6 netcode
sings no matter who I'm fighting or
incredibly which server I'm logged into
I made sure to log into the North
America South America and Asia servers
during my review time and nearly every
match I played in all three felt like my
opponent was sitting in the room next to
me that's not to say it's perfect as
personal internet connections are also a
major factor in performance but the
Advent of rollback netcode has been a
major Boon to the entire fighting game
genre and 35 is the latest beneficiary I
had a couple of matches in the North
America region that did have some
netcode issues but my online play
experience as a whole has been
overwhelmingly positive fighting games
in the Modern Age live on through their
extra content and 356 is no exception
Capcom has not only confirmed the first
four characters coming via downloadable
content but much like 355 the game will
feature its own economy complete with
multiple currencies Drive tickets are
earned in game and fighter coins can be
earned in-game or purchased separately
as well as this there's a battle pass
which will offer Avatar gear emotes and
other perks in both a free and premium
track given how strong the base game is
having more content and being able to
play the game in different ways is an
exciting prospect I can't get enough of
three Fire Sticks it's been my last
thought when I go to bed and my first
thought when I wake up in the morning it
has a beautifully constructed fighting
system but also offers modes that take
the game very seriously and in other
cases not seriously at all there are
some small issues with performance in
World Tour but none of those are enough
to derail the overall package with the
releases of new Tekken and more combat
games it very much feels like we're in a
new golden era for the fighting game
genre thankfully Street Fighter 6 steps
into the arena looking good and fighting
fairly
[Music]
we get it
my dad tells stories of a terrible war
that happened across the sky
Heroes fought
and died to give us a chance to start
over
[Applause]
all that I know from their Earth are the
creatures they sent along with us
[Applause]
and here on a rot every day is a fight
to survive
[Music]
but if anyone can team this new world we
can
[Music]
we have always known war
foreign
[Music]
now our Oaths are lost
forsaken
and you must face the monsters
[Music]
our sins have borne
is an oath worth the weight of a crown
[Music]
the world is filled with stories
of Legendary Heroes
[Music]
and treacherous villains
a Fantastical creatures
and wondrous places
where nature
live in Perfect Harmony
not all stories have happy endings
[Music]
yours has yet to be written
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
what's happened
foreign
[Music]
hey folks I'm current Divina and I just
got the chance to see 30 minutes of
Allen week to gameplay it was hands off
but there's a lot to talk about and I
have a lot of Impressions to share with
you
before we jump right into this there's a
few things I need to clear up and that
is some stuff I love one I love Alan
Wake two I love survival horror and
three I'm a big old fan of detective
mystery games and not only when they
first announce Alan Wake 2 as a survival
hordge and my mind explode but what I
saw was a trifecta of all those things
because Alan Wake 2 is just as much a
survival horror as it is a detective
investigation game and that's got this
guy very excited so what I got to see
was basically an extended look at what
was revealed at summer game Fest the
gameplay I saw surrounded around Saga
Anderson and her investigating cauldron
lake with her partner Alex Casey with a
single button press Saga teleports to
the mine place was an actual physical
room that you can move around in that
shows your evidence board as well as a
map a place to upgrade your weapons and
also do profiling which we'll get more
into in a moment as you collect evidence
you are able to actually physically
place the evidence on the wall on your
own to be able to connect your own dots
which is something I'm extremely excited
for because it feeds into my detective
loving heart so if you're not familiar
the Crux of the scheme is that Saga is
trying to find Alan Wake or at least
investigate what happened uh in bright
Falls 13 years ago and what unravels is
this big old horrific
cultist focused thing where there's
ritualistic killings and that bleeds out
into many many more Mysteries and things
that are Supernatural uh that of course
in one way or another align with what
has happened to Alan awake in order to
progress in the world and get more of a
connection to the dark place which is
where Alan Wake is trapped from the
first game actually connecting evidently
find helps Saga make connections that
actually manifest things from the dark
place into reality which is what allows
the player to progress kind of allowing
this puzzle like element but of course
it's not just about the investigation
because it is also yes indeed a
full-blown survival horror I'm talking a
limited inventory inventory management
scarce resources and Incredibly Close
Quarter combat uh that was extremely
intense to watch so in the demo we saw
Saga face up against who what I assume
is one of these ritualistic killing
dudes uh wearing a face mask and even
that fight was just extremely grueling
they're intense they murmur to
themselves you also have many things in
Your Arsenal like uh one of the things
that's coming back from the first game
is flashing your light on these things
to get rid of this Darkness this this
sort of like Supernatural thing that is
shielding them which gives you an
opportunity to then shoot them open up a
spot sometimes use a flare which will
then show other weak spots for you able
to hit now for those of you who are
familiar with the first one you may know
that that's really more of an action
adventure and the combat has been
criticized for being a little repetitive
over time of just like flashing a
flashlight and a dude and then shooting
them repeat and while remedy has
vocalized that they aware of that
concern that is something that kind of
held the first one back uh they're going
into this one without awareness but
without being able to play it
for the most part it did seem like that
similar routine of flashing your light
on this dude getting rid of this
darkness and then you shoot now of
course it did seem much more in close
quarters uh the flashlight like using
the flashlight seems to work even
quicker but that's kind of a good
balance considering that the enemies are
now more up close and personal also one
thing I saw there was less enemies but
they were more aggressive than they were
in the first one the first one
definitely like threw horrors of these
dudes at you while you were just like
shooting light at them shooting them
light shoot light shoot the closest
thing I can compare it to in a way is
sort of Resident Evil 2 combat
specifically because the Resident Evil 2
combat is always really up close it's in
close quarters and you're usually only
facing off a few zombies at a time but
it can still feel really dire and while
that had a similar feeling and weight in
just from what I saw I still have a
concern whether or not you know this
routine of flashlight shooting
flashlight shooting uh will actually
like stick through for an entire
campaign but of course in traditional
survival horror that also means that
there's a great deal of exploration
there's a great deal of slower pacing
especially time to build a brooding
atmosphere and also of course resource
management and some minor puzzle solving
during my time Saga saw you there was a
shotgun behind a glass case and in order
to get the shotgun you would have to
find a Post-It note that then would give
you a clue to the combination for the
lock that would then give you the
shotgun and that's like sort of like
that is the Symmetry that I'm looking
for or when I'm when I'm playing the
survival War because it kind of gives me
the agency in that I don't need to get
that gun if I don't need to but then
there's that sense of like you know
puzzle solving involved that just that
feeds into the things of most but of
course this wouldn't be a remedy or even
an allen weight game without its
atmosphere so again this is in the
Pacific Northwest or at least the
section I saw with Saga and it is
brooding and that's where some of the
elements from control I started to see
really bleed through aesthetically there
was this fantastic part where you go
into what is called the overlap that is
where the dark place starts to feed into
reality and it's this incredible moment
of saga just like walking through a
forest with these flashing ominous red
lights that have no Source whatsoever
this tense White Noise just building uh
and it was like it's this sort of flow
of like
investigating a putting of putting
evidence together action tense combat
but also the opportunity to explore and
let something sink in that really really
made what I saw feel effective and kind
of like the last bit of like the whole
investigative part is of course
profiling not don't only do just peace
evidence together but you actually have
the opportunity to sit at a table with
pictures of characters you've met and
you actually have to ask yourself
questions and ask them the right
questions will then unlock things within
saga's mind and putting herself in like
the shoes of the people she's trying to
profile profiling people is necessary to
not only gather evidence but also piece
things together so you can manifest it
from the dark place into reality and
it's just this is the trifecta I'm
talking about like The Surreal spooky
dark uh nature of the game with
investigative stuff I love it I'm a big
fan I'm excited uh but that isn't to say
it was very specific that the developers
also told me it's quirky it's a quirky
game it's retaining it's kind of Twin
Peaks isms that we saw in the first one
and that remedy just seems to have to a
T through all their games now if you're
new to Alan Wake don't worry it is not
necessary for you to play the first one
also that said it's this is a game
that's connected to remedy's other
titles like control and even Quantum
break in some small little ways but that
is not necessary like to be able to be
invested in the lore to understand Alan
Wake 2 they're being very transparent
that this should be an entry point for
anyone despite how involved you are in
uh remedies other games so with that
being said I only got to see a sliver of
it there's still a lot that I have to
see and thankfully uh you can actually
go to gamespot.com we'll have a link in
the description below for my actual
written editorial piece uh which will
give some insight to some of the
developers I got to talk to and give a
little bit more insight but that being
said this is a game that I've been
wanting to see for 13 years and it's
kind of remarkable not only see it
finally happen but see it connecting the
dots in ways that just feeds into things
I really really like but we will have to
find out more when the game releases
this year on October 17th
foreign
don't be alarmed my name is Gemini we'll
talk later when we're safe
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
you can't sneak past me die
thank you
I'll kill you both then string you up on
the bridge
foreign
come true
seeing you like this
I understand why some people despise me
I invented the puppets after all
I should take responsibility as their
maker
but in order for me to do that
I need to take care of the puppets at
City Hall
you help me
son
take this
you'll find it most useful
[Music]
we're gonna fly
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
three
two
one
[Music]
it's hard to express how excited all of
us at Bethesda are to be here with you
today we're so grateful you're spending
the time and we know you've waited a
long time to finally see Starfield it's
easily our most ambitious game ever like
our previous games it's an epic
role-playing game where you get to be
who you want and go where you want but
this time you'll be exploring space so
let's Jump Right In This is early in the
game as you arrive on the mysterious
moon of Crete
thank you
[Music]
according to the scanners the abandoned
research facility is in this direction
thank you
foreign
[Music]
it would appear that pirates of the
Crimson Fleet are using the facility
foreign
[Music]
on the roof
hey
[Music]
you're gonna pay for that
thank you
after some initial encounters you're
invited to join constellation who in the
future the game is set in are the last
group of Space Explorers to meet them
you'll head to the capital city of New
Atlantis
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to Constellation we have a lot
to talk about
we're all here but because we're
committed biggest question of
what's out there
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for
as to what they are
what they're building
you will be part of solving that puzzle
now
so you found something the new guy found
it you dug up the artifact right that
means you saw it the Visions
the artifact you found appears to be one
of many scattered across the Galaxy if
we can find Moon we can unlock Secrets
beautiful isn't it The Man Who Sold me
this told me that it spoke to him of
course the settled systems is full of
groups with other priorities
quickly doesn't follow the rules agree
to work for UC sister and together we
take down this Cutthroat Pirates
we're not just here to shoot the bad
guys we're peacekeepers we project the
people to the Freestar Collective when
you sign up with a crimson Fleet no one
quits the only way out
is death the path ahead may be dangerous
we are not stopping
most dusties don't even make it this far
this road
we'll change
[Music]
forever
that gives you a look at the stories in
Starfield But ultimately it's not our
story it's the story you create by who
you are and the choices you make and
that starts with character creation
[Music]
it's our most flexible yet
you can customize all the elements of
how you look
[Music]
you'll pick a background that gives you
three starting skills
[Music]
it's here you spend some time as a
diplomat having a way with words might
prove useful there are optional traits
and these come with unique advantages
and disadvantages
but it's not just in how you can look
and how your character plays and
develops
[Music]
the skill system combines the best from
our previous games and you can unlock
new skills as you level up and then you
rank those skills up by using them and
completing challenges and there's deep
crafting systems from running research
projects with resources you find to
crafting weapon mods and needed to
survive
and you can build your own outposts
these act as a home away from home for
survival and resource generation you can
choose where and how to build each one
and you can hire characters you meet to
keep it up and running
but
that's not all
[Music]
you can even build your own spaceships
you can choose crew members
and yes you can completely customize the
look and layout
there's loads of different modules ship
manufacturers and more
[Music]
it's so cool we just absolutely love
this
foreign
it's not just how the ship looks it's
how it performs from engines to Shields
to weapon systems because yes you can
fly it
[Music]
thank you
we can't wait for all of you to
experience the game thanks again for
being with us today and thanks for all
the support you've given us over the
decades especially on this game it's
been an incredible journey for us making
it but we know that's really only the
beginning for it's when all of you play
it that the real Journey Begins
and you may be wondering just how big is
this game
so we thought we'd take one last moment
and show you
let's take a look at one of our planets
jemisin
you can land in new Atlantis
but you can also land and explore
anywhere on the planet
and it's not just this planet it's all
the planets in the system
from Barren but resource heavy ice balls
to Goldilocks planets with life
and not just this system
but over a hundred systems over 1 000
planets all open for you to explore
we can't wait to see what you find
[Music]
thank you
on behalf of hexworks Welcome to the
Lords of the Fallen gameplay showcase
today we're taking a closer look at our
all-new dark fantasy action RPG arriving
this October on PC PS5 and Xbox series
xns
[Music]
a spiritual successor to the original
2014 release it acts as a full reboot
for the franchise taking place in a vast
interconnected world over a thousand
years later
featuring colossal boss battles fast
challenging combat and deep immersive
storytelling players will journey across
two parallel Realms in this expansive
RPG experience the world of the living
Axiom and the world of the Dead
Umbro with each featuring its own unique
Pathways characters enemies and of
course Treasures
and while Axiom presents its own
challenges Untold Horrors await in its
nightmarish counterpart
thanks to the umbral lamp players can
enter this flightless world at any time
in one of two ways when slain by the
foes of Axiom at which point you'll
resurrect in the same location albeit in
umbral
or by performing The umbral Rift and
willingly sacrificing one of your two
lives
but the lamb holds yet more power
granting the ability to Flay the soul
from an enemy for some high damage
attacks and even manipulate the very
environment of the umbral world
however the longer you spend in this
wraith ridden plane the greater number
of spectral Terrors that will hunt you
down
but as harrowing as the hellions of
umbrellar they pale in comparison to the
game's brutal boss battles
towering above the ever burning city of
kaurath this Garden can't you in
monstrosity doesn't take kindly to would
be adventurers the Demonic presence
within ready to devour any and all
within sight
a merciless torturer prepared to carry
out any atrocity in the name of his
faith tancred master of castigations is
The Devout chaplain of the hallowed
Sentinels though beneath the pious
failed his very own flesh conceals a
truth most powerful
when Harrow or darvlon ventured into the
deepest depths of this world to thwart
the undead Rising what she discovered
was so utterly horrific that she
renounced her former life and commitment
to a far darker oath
pre-order Lords of the Fallen now and
prepare to unleash the darkness on
Friday the 13th of October
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
songs
we got it
please
[Music]
thank you
it's sometimes difficult to reconcile
that Diablo 3 is over a decade old its
release was polarizing for a number of
reasons but its evolving formula of
action role-playing endured enjoying a
Resurgence with his post-launch
expansion that carried through years of
ongoing seasonal updates it shouldn't
come as a surprise then that each of
those years helped to inform the design
of Diablo IV a game which confidently
delivers gameplay that has been carried
forward and refined from the overload 2
and 3 while also establishing a strong
foundation for the franchise's future
foreign
games have always contained stories for
their single player campaigns but you'd
be forgiven for thinking of past
storylines as merely contextualization
for the game's primary focus dungeon
crawling that's where Diablo 4 makes one
of its most striking changes it not only
takes its story far more seriously but
it tells one that's far more engrossing
than ever before as a traveling Wanderer
you come across a small town of villages
on a snow-capped mountain range looking
for some Aid after killing some
creatures and returning you're welcomed
as a hero and given food and shelter
only for the villagers to try and use
you in a ritual sacrifice to Lilith
co-creator of sanctuary and recently
resurrected antagonists of this tale
this encounter links you to Lilith
driving you forward on a quest to stop
her plan of amassing an army for her own
nefarious purposes
by mother's blood
thy mother's body
so shall you witness her glory
before you die
much of that sounds like standard Diablo
Fair there's a big bad demon and you're
the only one who can stop it but Diablo
4 makes intelligent use of Lilith
layering her motivation slowly to the
point where you can't help but consider
her side of the argument she's not
driven solely by a Lust For Destruction
instead she's grieving with the place
she once created to escape the endless
cycle of War Between Heaven and Hell now
being used as a staging ground to
continue it she's an antagonist that has
been slighted by those she trusted at
every turn and while her means of
exacting Justice provide the reason for
your entire crusade in the first place
it's surprising and equally welcome when
Diablo 4 forces you to slow down and
consider the true goal of your struggle
not just any demon
the daughter of hatred the mother of
sanctuary the trop of the Soul Survivor
has been tried and tested in Diablo for
years and Diablo 4 doesn't completely
change that instead it puts a much
larger emphasis on companions than ever
before with most acts centered around a
new party member rather than a demon
you're eventually hunting down an early
standout is Vigo a prideful Knight who
is forced to endure a conscious ruining
loss after a single selfish action it's
not just vigo's remorse that is
heart-wrenchingly conveyed but also the
horrors of his eventual Redemption
leading to one of the more powerful
character moments in the entire game
vigo's story is a teaser for many
similar arcs that follow all of which do
a great job of providing a cause for
your character to join your fight while
also contextualizing their motivations
to continue or abstain from the enduring
conflict this applies to most of the
Allies you recruit in your fight against
the lift Each of which has their own
motivations that feel faithful to their
respective Journeys it's a level of care
I can't recall being given to many past
Diablo Companions and Diablo 4 certainly
makes far more liberal use of them
through the campaign to make them feel
purposeful bringing together this ragtag
group takes place over Diablo 4's
extensive sex acts some of which you can
tackle in different orders previous
Diablo titles had each Act accompanied
by a change in Locale but in Diablo 4 it
only takes a few moments before you're
given free reign to explore its
intimidatingly large interconnected map
here you can transition from frigid
mountaintops to desolate deserts in just
a matter of minutes with the
transitional areas doing a good job of
masking an otherwise jarring change
having a static layout that you can
learn and get comfortable with induced
Exploration with a greater sense of
wonder than previous hubs which were
often filled with enemies to kill before
diving into the next dungeon the
geography also gives towns and larger
cities a sense of place on a bigger map
each distinct area is shown off of a
great amount of visual detail with
Diablo 4 incorporating a delightfully
Macabre style that is befitting of its
violent story it's not trying to overly
correct some of the criticisms laid on
Diablo 3 either with pops of color used
Tastefully to highlight areas of Hope
and kinship that contrast against the
broader Strokes of dread and fair
painting the rest of the landscape
things don't always hold up when the
camera Zooms in to give conversations a
cinematic feel as a degradation in
detail on character models and
environments is a little more
discernible regardless it's still a
striking presentation that looks
incredible in motion while also keeping
information clear enough to read when
fights get chaotic foreign
the moment-to-moment action Diablo 4 is
one of its strongest traits which is for
the best given how genre defining the
series has been over the years there's
an argument to be made that Diablo 3
went too far in the direction of
simplification and that's exactly where
Diablo 4 course corrects in smart ways
you're still limited to a total of six
Active abilities at a time four on your
hop bar and two on each Mouse button for
those on PC but how you construct your
build is no longer linear instead each
new level lets you invest a point in a
branching skill tree with each of its
core notes branching further out into
new abilities and Associate passive
perks you need to invest a certain
number of total points that continue
unlocking each of these nodes so you
will have to think carefully about
abilities and how they serve your
greater build it's a system that allows
for a lot of flexibility letting you
experiment with focusing on one specific
ability as the foundation of your build
or dabbling with ways to combine two
entirely different paths such as
empowering your summon skeletons while
also firing off loads of blood infused
magic as a necromancer
oh
experimentation is further encouraged by
Diablo 4's low cost Respec and unlimited
chances to do so unlike the more
punishing approach in Diablo 2 you can
completely redefine your build at any
time for a small fee of in-game gold
approaching your skill tree with a
different idea or mindset or just making
some small changes to adjust for a
difficult fight this freedom is
empowering in a similar way to that of
Diablo 3's fluid build system but it
still requires you to engage
meaningfully with synergies to make your
builds viable it feels like the
culmination of all the ways previous
games in the series have allowed you to
play while catering to as many play
Styles as possible but without many of
the critical compromises from the last
time out the cost for respect does
naturally increase the higher level but
it never went to a point where I felt it
was too expensive in relation to the
amount of gold I was earning at the time
thanks to this system I felt free to
continually change up my approach to my
Necromancer I started with a combination
of skeleton summoning Shadow damaging
attacks and some blood spells for
survivability the necromancer's unique I
believe lets me either summon minions
from corpses or sacrifice the ability
entirely for Passive advantage Ages
which led me to realize that I could
theoretically play a necromancer
entirely as a pseudo Mage with Blood and
Bone abilities after some taxing boss
battles I decided to go all in on a
summoning build that accentuated the
abilities of my skeleton soldiers Mages
and large hulking Golem Each of which
had three different variations that
could combine to find the perfect
Synergy it was consistently satisfying
to find a build that worked for a couple
of hours and then completely change it
either through necessity or curiosity
seeing small decisions manifest as big
changes in terms of overall viability
gives me faith that each class is going
to be picked apart for various
approaches that maximize elements of
different play Styles while the skill
tree is where you will ultimately
establish the basis of your build
aspects of Power are a new facet of the
role-playing formula that allows you to
hone it these collectible skills so to
speak can be combined with rare pieces
of gear to turn them into custom
legendary items imbued with the exact
ability that complements the build
you're constructing this alleviates some
of the headaches associated with
grinding out dungeons in the hopes of a
particularly legendary piece of gear
dropping while also providing a new
Avenue of options for build construction
that isn't to say it diminishes the rush
of a big legendary drop though Legendary
Weapons can often feature the same
abilities as aspects do but will
regularly have better percentage roles
on their effectiveness making them the
ideal path to the most optimal late game
build still
aspects of Power are obtained by
clearing the many dungeons sprawl around
the map Each of which feature their own
multi-stage objective to complete some
are as simple as killing enemies and
depositing their souls to progress
further While others require you to hunt
down a specific foe in search of a key
that lets you reach lower levels of the
dungeon each of these concludes with a
boss fight which for the most part are
less interesting than those found in the
main story dungeons bosses throughout
the story are multi-layered bouts with
shifting enemy attacks that can
completely change the landscape you're
fighting in forcing you to consistently
think about positioning and when the
best moment for an attack is bosses in
these more common dungeons lack that
sense of complexity and I often found
masculine Warriors completely
overwhelming many of them to the point
where many of the bosses would just
stand in place and attack until dead
thank you
given the sheer number of dungeons on
offer it might not have been possible to
retain the same level of tension across
every boss encounter but when you're
bouncing between several of these as you
grab aspects of power throughout your
campaign it's difficult not to notice
the stark contrast and quality between
the two as with any Diablo title Diablo
4 is nowhere near complete once you've
rolled credits on the campaign Walter's
return to incentivize you to go through
everything again with a high degree of
difficulty but also more rewards to reap
it's welcomed that Diablo 4 retains the
option that allows you to jump into more
challenging World tiers from the very
start this time preventing a potentially
frustrating first playthrough devoid of
any meaningful challenge outside of
increasing world here the map becomes
littered with additional side activities
that join regular side quests rotating
open mode Dynamic quests similar to the
Patrols in Destiny 2 and strongholds
strongholds are extremely hostile areas
that are densely populated with enemies
usually a level or two higher than you
providing a larger challenge to overcome
than regular groups or foes around the
open world minor objectives also make
this feel like a smaller scale open-air
dungeon with new waypoints and Merchants
usually unlocked once you've rid the
area of the threat
so
larger-scale World boss fights that are
best tackled with numerous other players
you will find in the open world are also
available although no multiplayer
features were available during the
review period finally Whispers of the
Dead encapsulate time bounties that pop
up throughout the world with each one
rewarding you with an additional
currency that can be turned in for
caches of gems weapons and More Night
messages which can be obtained through
completing Whispers of the Dead quests
can be used to unlock additional
nightmare dungeons these add new
modifiers to existing dungeons around
the map that can do anything from change
the type of enemies you encounter to
Rolling new random abilities they might
have at their disposal with the Allure
of even rarer loot drops enticing you to
run them over and over again
there's a familiar but equally expensive
framework in place already in Diablo 4
that should satiate you across multiple
playthroughs with plans already detailed
by a blizzard to expand on this through
seasons of new content similar to that
of Diablo 3. now
crew work begins Diablo 4 at this time
cannot Escape comparison to the past of
the franchise it belongs to but it's
thankfully a game that has been crafted
with a strong awareness of what made
each one either revered or reviled it
represents a measured approach to
combining the many elements from
previous entries that worked into a
system that feels like the new standard
Bearer for Action role-playing coupled
with a new Benchmark for storytelling in
the franchise and a solid narrative
foundation for any potential new
adventures it's easy to see a Diablo 4
as something I'll regularly check out
for a long time to come
thank you
[Music]
it unlocks our path to the Future
a future made possible because of the
price you paid
[Music]
your sacrifice
will not have been in vain
We Begin by hearing an old wise sounding
voice
when we see a quiet peaceful setting
this will make our game seem big and
important now something must break the
serenity
will this creature be in the game
say goodbye to it forever
and suddenly and for no reason
these pointless slow motion shots make
everything you seem cool and should
bolster pre-sale numbers
sound can mean only one thing
we must gaze over an epic shot of a
world and should be lens flares
now we see our heroes but only the
silhouette because the developers
haven't finished the design
or finish the story
all finished any gameplay that's
actually ready to show in fact the only
thing they have finished
[Music]
it's the typo
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
last question Dr darling are you sure
the perimeter surrounding the zone is
really enough if a powerful emission
were to occur we would listen The Zone
has remained stable for years besides we
didn't establish the most advanced
institution in human history without
first guaranteeing its safety as the
head of the scientific Institute for
research of the Chernobyl area or a
circle for short I believe the Wonders
that we will bring to the world far
outweigh the potential risks how big are
these risks exactly
The Zone reveals A Whole New World we
can stick with the old one fearing
change but tell me
do you want our descendants to remember
us as cowards or as those who dared to
venture forwards to a new better
Humanity
we're evacuated I remind our listeners
that a similar incident happened in our
region quite recently ruining homes and
livelihoods
thank you
however City officials urge people to
stay
ignoring them the situation is totally
understand
[Music]
foreign
so this is usually the bit where I take
a bunch of stuff out of the locker and
there's like a really cool Montage but I
have nothing to take out because we're
talking about Game Pass which is
entirely digital
and also it has been around for six
years
it is the service that has become
synonymous with the phrase the greatest
deal in gaming and rightfully so it has
had a tremendous impact on the way many
of us play games
me included no really it has
it has changed me over the years of
being a Game Pass subscriber my
relationship with games how I buy them
play them and what console I choose to
play them on has been dramatically
altered honestly it's kind of debatable
whether or not that's a good or bad
thing because I think it's a little bit
of both in fact the whole thing has got
me asking is Game Pass changing how I or
how we all value games
[Music]
when I take a step back and reflect on
the past six years my thoughts are
usually always it's been great I've
never been this versed in games before I
get to try things I otherwise wouldn't
and yada yada and that is all true but
there's another side to this and no two
games better illustrate my relationship
with Game Pass than ghostwire Tokyo and
Hi-Fi rush and by the way both those
games are actually by the exact same
developer Tango Gameworks which is
completely coincidental really let's
start with ghostwire Tokyo when
ghostwire Tokyo was revealed it was
showcased as a PlayStation exclusive it
had the devs Behind The Evil Within it
was a new IP it was spooky paranormal
and Fantastical it seemed by all
accounts like a Kurt game however around
the same time it was revealed Microsoft
announced its acquisition of Tango's
parent company Bethesda softworks which
meant its days as a PS5 exclusive or
inevitably numbered it was only a matter
of time until it made its way on to Game
Pass so despite my interest in the game
I held off I didn't bite in the hopes
that it would eventually come to the
subscription service as a result a game
that I was actually pretty excited for
was shoved to the back of my mind until
a year later when it did indeed come to
Game Pass and oh yes that was a
pre-install all right now on the Hi-Fi
Rush
during an Xbox showcase earlier this
year Tango Gameworks revealed an all-new
hyper-stylized cartoonishly over-the-top
Rhythm action game it looked really cool
and then out of nowhere like a Nintendo
Direct mic drop we're happy to tell you
that you can play Hi-Fi Rush tonight
that made it suddenly even cooler the
results swept through headlines and blew
up my Twitter feed an absolute slam dunk
of a surprise and yeah I instantly
installed it
here's the thing if Hi-Fi Rush had just
launched as a regular game at a regular
price without the support of Game Pass I
know I would have most likely passed on
it nothing against it like at all I just
know that if I had to vote with my
dollars I probably would have put those
dollars somewhere else maybe even
ghostwire Tokyo but because it launched
on Game Pass a service that I browse
almost every single day I had nothing to
lose but to give it a shot and you know
what
it's pretty good and you know what I
didn't think was very good ghostwire
Tokyo
about that sinking for a second
oh and also another important point that
involves both those games is that I
haven't finished either one of them
and I likely won't so what do I do with
this realization on one hand there was a
game I wanted waited and stalled it
played it for a few hours and decided it
wasn't for me but on the other hand was
a game I wouldn't have played but
because it was available to me I did and
end up enjoying it but I still did not
finish it when I realized this it had me
starting to look a little closer at my
overall habits with the greatest deal in
gaming some of my favorite games are on
Game Pass new and old ones some of which
are from a pre-game pass world Grim
Fandango Paradise killer 999 the Yakuza
series While others I got to play
because of Game Pass Norco immortality
hellblade gun grave Gore but the thing
is I realized while I was scrolling
through all the games of Game Pass
there's really only a handful and then
some that I've actually seen to the end
otherwise there is a a graveyard of
Unfinished games on my hard drive
Proteus scorn tunic signalus The
Pedestrian pentiment and of course Hi-Fi
rush and ghost wire Tokyo or how about
the games I installed and just haven't
even touched like Somerville Ninja
Gaiden and The Artful Escape yeah I
don't really feel great about it also I
realized that like half these games that
like I have installed or from Game Pass
aren't actually even on Game Pass
anymore that's how long it's
for me to get around to some of these
games are just completely abandon them
for you know reasons of course I'm a
strong believer in the mentality that if
you don't want to finish a book
then you shouldn't and similar to books
games require a little more engagement
from you compared to something say like
movies or TV shows and to me it becomes
more about your time and attention as
the measurement of value rather than the
actual dollar amount when I think about
my time with ghostwire Tokyo or even
HiFi Rush would I have spent more time
with them maybe even viewed them
differently if I had actually purchased
them I honestly don't know but it's
enough to unravel my entire perception
of why I buy and play what I do versus
what I don't oh and speaking of when I
actually do buy a game I'm most likely
buying it on Xbox because it has become
my primary console and I owe that to
Game Pass
which is actually maybe really the point
here if I'm measuring success in my time
then well Xbox has won it because
regardless of whether or not I'm playing
a game on Game Pass or not I'm still
turning my Xbox on every day more than
any of the other consoles which was not
the case a few years back in fact I made
an entire video about that and how my
perception of Microsoft has changed to
say the least I wasn't even an Xbox user
until Game Pass came along that's game
passes crowning achievement over the
past six years getting people to talk
about Xbox and spend time on its
consoles and in the process it has
raised the bar for what will motivate me
to actually spend money on a game it
makes me think about the games I haven't
played or have not bought in hopes that
they will come to a service like Game
Pass games like the Callisto protocol
like ghostwire Tokyo there's a lot going
for the cluster protocol that had me
interested I love survival horror it was
deemed as a dead space spiritual
successor despite Dead Space remake
releasing only a month later and yet I
wasn't entirely sold on it you might
assume that it's because of the review
scores but it wasn't I actually have an
entire video about that that you should
consider watching it was that it didn't
seem interesting or compelling enough it
just had me curious at best which to me
is the quintessential sign of a I'll
just wait for Game Pass sort of game
even just saying that makes it feel like
I'm devaluing the games that do launch
the game pass which is not the case at
all this is just how my brain works now
so much so that if the callista protocol
was on PlayStation's game catalog Sony's
answer to Game Pass then maybe just
maybe I'd actually consider subscribing
to a whole other service just to play it
and that left in of itself is a messed
up situation for me to unpack that I
wouldn't consider playing a game that I
was interested in unless it was a part
of a subscription service like Game Pass
I would rather pay 15 extra a month to
play a game that on paper takes all of
my boxes rather than just Fork up
seventy dollars for a game that I may
even potentially love I at least know
that I'm not the only one that shifted
in some sort of way because of Game Pass
after all PlayStation did make the game
catalog the exact same model as Game
Pass and has been using it as a means to
Showcase some cool games like Humanity
or even stray as Day One releases for
the service I Still Love Game Pass and
I'm still gonna use it as a means to
dabble and experiment and try things
because that is what I'm paying for one
way or another it demonstrates that we
are living in a post game pass world at
the moment and I'm having a hard time
imagining a pivot back
you know what
[__] it I'm buying the cluster protocol
thank you
[Music]
Ed
with our swords we will Forge new
stories to strike the gods that haunt us
you might see me as weak
but I will show you what lies behind my
eyes
suffering
soothe our scars of grief and break
their Siege of our minds you
human gods
and show you what lies behind their eyes
thank you
it's coming
it knows our
own how does it know to risk your own
life for what you believe is your
sacrifice to make
you can lead others to death
brings a different kind of Burden
one that's Cinema would have to learn
oh God
I don't know
dad is coming
can you smell that fear
the bones
look at the bones that's going to be you
everyone
[Music]
stay down
those whose eyes are clouded by fear of
published by the ghosts that haunt them
senua saw that to win the war we must
break this Siege break it
with an unshakable truth
with an impossible feat
yes yes
[Music]
thank you
everybody
shut them down
ah
God
hello again for the first time you've
seen nothing I saw nothing anything okay
it's absolutely fine
everything's fine uh we were you know
just uh seeing if you could read lips um
yeah you know like one of when uh it
sound good decent no I don't know Xbox
happy Xbox day everyone happy Easter
XBox Happy Easter eggs um that's a
reference to if you've never seen the
Usher Dance Central Xbox videos they are
some of the greatest promotional
marketing materials I have ever seen and
I will I think that's one of the best
things Xbox has ever done he's not only
he's the greatest dancer of all time
yeah yes but he's the greatest
absolutely Happy Valentine's Day Xbox
happy happy Christmas Xbox anyways hi we
should probably talk about what we are
going to be talking about today and
seeing today so obviously yes it is the
Xbox uh summer showcase and obviously we
also have the Starfield direct we're
gonna get a big look at Bethesda game
studios upcoming uh what is it the first
new IB in 25 years very exciting I'm
just James I'm joined by cut in Davina
greetings
hello I'm Kurt and tomorrow Hussein
greetings and salutations I'm Kurt okay
well guys we can't just keep repeating
ourselves uh we're gonna have to come up
with some unique uh intros but no it's
good to see everyone I'm very excited
about this one it's uh it's gonna be an
interesting show for Xbox I feel because
the narrative around uh you know they
have had a bit of a
um a bit of an up and down year you know
folks who's very stoked about stuff like
Hi-Fi Rush uh and uh you know the
reception of that and then unfortunately
redfall did not land with the good uh he
didn't learn the way people hoped
um ourselves included uh but now people
are there's good Buzz around this
showcase people are very excited uh
briefly before we get kind of into the
nitty-gritty what do you uh what are
your hopes for today what do you uh what
are you expect to see
um yeah I think it's an interesting kind
of inflection point in Xbox's current
kind of road map or their progress they
had a a real table setting period where
they were you know acquiring Studios
building up the kind of
um kind of development and timeline kind
of stuff and the the the uh narrative
for them has always been yes we know
we're light right now but we're
basically putting these dominoes down in
place to knock them down when the time
comes we finally started approaching
that time and the narrative completely
got taken over by the fact that red four
came out and it was supposed to be the
first big part of this Domino kind of
effect and it kind of dropped the ball
um and it took over that that is a
narrative now so I think what I'm
looking forward to most is hopefully
Xbox showing how they're going to bounce
back and they already have a lot of
things in place to do that some of them
have been leaked like the Persona stuff
which is awesome yeah but I think like
the the I'm I'm excited to see what
first parties stuff they have Fable has
obviously been the worst kept secret in
British game development of all time
yeah I mean we heard about that before
we moved yeah I've I've I when I joined
the games industry 10 years ago someone
told me you know they're making a new
fail
um and like everyone knows that their
favorite was happening
um and yeah so I'm excited to finally
see that it will be a great opportunity
to see a kind of a studio kind of Branch
out as well but beyond that Phil
bigfield has said we've got games that
people don't know about so the stuff
that I'm excited about is seeing that
maybe that was Persona if it was yike no
I think there'll be there'll be more
we'll go through stuff yeah for sure and
also we're just flagging it now ahead of
time very excitingly we are gonna have
Phil Spencer and Matt Booey coming to
the Giant Bomb couch tonight around 8pm
PPT
um we briefly saw them yesterday there's
uh they're not backing out okay we
double checked they were very excited
they were actually very cannot wait to
be there so I'm gonna watch our pre or
post show and they're like never mind
yeah no uh no so if you want to see into
you with Phil Spencer and Matt Bowie on
today of all days on Xbox day make sure
to come back Giant Bomb Knights tonight
8pm uh we'll be talking about it and
doing the whole thing but good what are
your hopes and dreams for today well
first I like you Tammy brought up the
good like table setting that was a good
analogy because that's been my feeling
for so long with with Xbox and Microsoft
like I've been very like I come from a
funky place where like I wasn't an Xbox
user until the past couple years you
made a great video about it thank you
very much I mean but like it's it's
there's been you know this like
this sort of like long game like you
know running a marathon sort of deal
that I think Xbox is doing right now and
like trying like this is a conversation
that's happened over and over again so
like but you know like they are
rebuilding themselves they they feel is
like they've been rebuilding themselves
for ages but it's been
a slow sort of turning of a massive ship
to rebuild your identity to like do
things that are prominent and important
to Gamers or changing even the
perspective of how we interact with
games Game Pass all not Jazz so
um I'm it's it's
we Xbox has had funky year but I you
know I do think we've had these sort of
wonderful moments like Hi-Fi Rush that
have unfortunately been shadowed by some
of the Yeah Yeah by redfall and some
other things but I still think there's
so many things we haven't seen there's
so many questions on answering because
there are so many developers that they
have that I think are so interesting and
so fascinating we haven't seen anything
from them in ages and I don't think
that's just gonna like
I don't think it's like they've gone
into the show yeah yeah
so uh I'm in general I'm always just a
little excited and a little positive to
see what Xbox is doing so
um even for the games that like I'm not
super like intimate or like like into
like I like Fable uh I play the first
two fables I wouldn't consider myself a
hardcore fan but like the problem Oh you
hate the British huh you don't like it
when we walk up to crowds and just fall
and everyone else yeah that's right I
mean I don't like it when you do that
well I'm never gonna stop condoms made
out of goat intestines yep yep yep it's
uh I mean historically accurate accurate
exactly uh but you know now that I work
with two British people how could I not
be excited for the next table made by
Forza team of all things like well well
not anxiety I mean I don't think you
know the person who designed hubcaps is
exactly gonna okay but I mean I hope it
is
I love the idea of like we're announcing
Fable but all the characters are cast we
can only do cars like we'd only know the
cars yeah and then the cars get jealous
if you're driving with cars yeah little
hearts around the cars yeah and if you
drive really badly then you start to
turn like red and dark snow coming out
here what is this why does this car
sound like John Cleese yeah well you
know I think coin that here we've coined
a couple game ideas
[Music]
finger guns finger guns right yeah but I
guess the last thing which I know I'm
not gonna see but I'm gonna just keep
saying to make sure people are aware
that I personally want to see it
Wolfenstein three I'm waiting for
Wolfenstein we can look we can talk
about it
I'm getting emotional about Wolfenstein
no it's genuinely because I haven't had
any social uh interaction and I've had
all of my social interactions the entire
year in one in two days three days yeah
we'll talk about uh I mean we know the
stuff that that is definitely confirmed
we're gonna get this big look at
Starfield uh Persona unfortunately
deadly we can just pretend we can
pretend I can yeah we've not seen any
moving footage of it yes as in with the
high quality stuff oh that wasn't an
Instagram that wasn't some Instagram
compressed video yeah that's fair
um but also yeah let's talk about
Wolfenstein so it is the Xbox Bethesda
Showcase with the Starfield all right I
do Wonder really how much Bethesda stuff
is going to be in there given I assume
all of the eggs are in the Starfield
basket for the remainder of the year uh
but Wolfenstein is a game that keeps
coming up because it's uh
yeah and I know they're doing Indiana
Jones now which is you know like
interesting to me I don't know if that's
going to be God if it's gonna be an
Indiana Jones where we see Indiana Jones
killing Nazis is the way I wanted to be
okay I do I do not I mean
well I know that's what you know so I
let's I'm interested to see how that
studio has done such like a pulp style
aggressive uh sort of interpretation
Wolfenstein what they do with Indiana
Jones but of course there's like the
Disney yeah I do wonder how that game is
going to be impacted by the latest movie
being pooped from above and like I
imagine they went in being like oh [__]
this is a good time for us to have you
know Harrison Ford's back um Harrison's
Ford is Harrison's getting his fought
out again no
um because
um like uh yeah I do imagine like if the
momentum behind that is gone I felt a
lot of it of the momentum for Indiana
Jones as a video game property is like
contingent on the developer making it
with machine games and like
I don't know I feel like they could do a
really good kind of first person style
uh action game and also have like a make
what they do work for Indiana Jones but
do I really want I I'm excited to see it
but I just don't care about Indiana yeah
you know what boys I can't even pretend
to care about it again
I like like the original Three movies
okay Sunday tea time viewing in the UK
um but I feel you know Indiana Jones 4
definitely took the wind out of the
sales
above doing Monkey [__] I was like I'm
done man I mean I even fleabag
apparently couldn't save this one
devastating I would that is devastating
for me I you know I uh
I would rather see
Wolfenstein 3 I would rather see machine
games do Wolfenstein three
um did you play
um the one the the co-op one with the
twins yeah I actually like that game
yeah it made me very motion sick I'm not
sure why because the other wolfensteins
don't no I actually like I played
through the entire game as Co-op like
it's not not as great as the other ones
but like yeah it has the writing and the
aesthetic and like the like the quips
that that they've like been able to
infuse into the wolf this new era
Wolfenstein DNA is all there like it
still is still great it also has like
it's still you can definitely tell like
you know
cutting floor Arcane stuff was
definitely yeah that game and works in
my opinion uh more than another
multiplayer Arcane game but um yeah
Charles fired have they not done a dog
version of the game we called it
Wolfenstein come on machine come on
coin it right here uh just to briefly
explain the mental gymnastics that I've
just done is that reminded me of the
time uh what didn't they do
um Skyrim stuff with dogs like they
dressed up around and so now uh Bethesda
game Studio that's really some mental
gymnastics uh we're gonna get a good
look at Starfield
how are you guys feeling about that at
this point because I feel I mean maybe
it's just uh been in the industry too
long but I feel every time I see a
trailer for a game up front and I know
that I'm gonna be into it there are
certain games I'm just like you don't
need to show me any more of it and with
Starfield you already had me with
Bethesda game Studio space you know yeah
Tim Curry space
uh that's all I wanted from it and so
every I'm not you know with Alan Wake
for example every new piece of
information like I was already there in
the trailer but I'm I'm going through
and I'm like oh my God what's up with Mr
scratch what's up with Jagger and
whatever anyway but with Starfield I'm
just like
I think the big question for them today
is going to be 30 or 60 frames per
second as much as I hate that because
that should not be the dominating
conversation but it will be and
especially after redfall
um what are you guys excited about if at
all about seeing with Starfield today I
think we need a more fleshed out kind of
or extended gameplay demo which is what
we're gonna get today so people
understand the loop a bit better and
because obviously our only frame of
reference is other Bethesda games video
games
um which is generally Skyrim or Oblivion
or that kind of stuff and so the only
framework we have to stick Starfield
into is those and I don't know if that's
doing a disservice to the game because
that's not what it is or if it's
accurate because that is pretty much
what it is but they're coming at it from
a new angle and have improved it we just
don't know either way like I think that
right now what we need is a Clarity a
bit more clarity on what that game is
going to be when people sit down and
play it and what the scale of it is for
from a kind of like broader perspective
and also like what kind of story are you
telling here like what because you know
I'm Elder Scrolls is a game about
freedom and exploration and Adventure
but also it's got an interesting story
it's got a world like maybe I'm being I
don't know and I'm being weirdo but I
like the story of Skyrim quite a bit
yeah and so one of the things I'm coming
to Starfield with is an interest in
narrative and characters and so far I've
seen little to nothing of it other than
space all right all right tell me what
is gonna happen am I going to learn you
know how to shout from a big spaceship
and fusrow die in space or whatever like
what's going on and I think that's what
I want out of it and also I think they
need to show off an extended look at
their game just to be like hey we've we
figured out how to stop it from
constantly breaking and like it looks
cleaner yeah
but I feel like I I also they need to be
like
here's what here's a baseline I'm not
going to show us the Baseline like the
junk comes when people get in there and
start doing weird stuff with it and I
love that but I also feel like they need
to kind of like hey we got one of these
games you know and the problem with the
jack is it becomes the narrative for a
really long time but it's like these
games are busted yet again what's going
on how is this train just a man wearing
a hat what's going on but there's also
tears to Jake all right like they're or
like like what I'm saying is like yeah
yeah yeah I mean the taste of the junk
is like a Skyrim running on Xbox folks
in PEC versus Skyrim running on PS3 yeah
but like you also have like you know
like you know uh like like sky like
cyberpunk
chain the launch sniper
you know one way or another like becomes
like a
official color that's added to that game
that happens after the fact though yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah when you see you know
dragons like yeah but once people have
gone through the entire experience and
like the game has been like
um kind of absorbed by The Wider gaming
culture that's when the jack is goes
from being how can you put this out too
this is fun dumb yeah so like they need
to get the first phase of it like sort
it and show that it's not gonna be a
moment where like all of it falls over
and it's like the PS3 versions of
Fallout or right Skyrim or whatever yeah
I guess like my thing my quick thing on
on Starfield is like I'm proud of the
same place you are where it's just like
I know I'm going to play it like I just
give it to me I just want to see it the
guest to your point
um scope is one of those things where
it's like you I forgot how many planets
they're like you can go to like
600 billion planets and I'm just like
okay but like what is that sounds
exhausting that looks like what does
that mean uh and that's like the only
that's the really only thing that I
really want to explain but
um I think starfield's in an interesting
spot as a Bethesda fan uh as a Skyrim
Fallout fan uh because we had Skyrim
Skyrim has still existed and still
existing in many ways a decade later
Fallout four has had several crystals
over its narrative and story so now we
have like and then of course Fallout 76
happened between that but
sorry Skyrim Fallout 4 and now star fuel
that feels like this this sort of I'm
interested to see this this Arc of where
like the Star Ford Starfield took and
learned from maybe criticism of the
narrative in Fallout 4 yeah and
obviously uh like the DNA and Foundation
they laid out that they like
they like Skyrim at that point so I just
came to me man I don't know a little
Game Spot exclusive we saw Todd
yesterday wearing the joke cast him he's
wearing the jacket he's wearing the
jackets wearing that jacket he looks
good are we sure he's like that's just
not his like skin
very well tailored jacket uh other games
uh let's we already talked a little bit
about Fable what's kept secret everyone
is a big uh expectations to see Fable
today
but also get some of the stuff in there
we could talk about so things like a
vowed yeah outer world two
um games that have been announced that
have kind of gone dark for a little bit
speaking of um
uh I mean one for me that I'm
very intrigued by they announced we saw
a little bit of but nothing else since
ever wild from rare uh the team who are
currently obviously behind games like
sea of Thieves
um which has been their main focus for
the past few years
um but I mean what I mean there's a lot
we could talk about you know silk song
yeah silk song it could be a really
interesting one I feel like
they're smart enough to know that's a
thing that a lot of people want and if
they can secure it and be like this is
this is the place where we'll tell you
the release date definitively I feel
like not just uh coming because they did
they were the last time to say like it
will be here in 12 months and then it
was not there in 12 months so I feel
like they have a to a degree like I'm
not upset about this but like oh I'm not
angry about internet but I feel like
internally I would be like we have a
responsibility to go back to this and
correct the record and give people a
concrete date that they can kind of um
you know Mark on their calendars so I
would love to see them that I'm also
kind of interested to see if we'll get
anything from Tango because Hi-Fi Rush
was a game that they said was kind of
made on the side right of Skunk Works
and even even like um Phil was like oh
we put out Hi-Fi rush and when we was
talking to kind of funny and stomach
Mike and Paris and Gary he was talking
about oh yeah people expected the evil
within three but we gave them
um Hi-Fi rush so my mind is like is
there an evil within three it could be
good time to do it and the genre is
still very healthy especially now that
Resident Evils come back and done some
amazing stuff with it and and Alan Wake
is popping off like pretty big they
could come out with an evil within three
and it'll be good timing
um but at the same time if their Tango
is doing something else entirely and we
get to see that that will be exciting as
well I think so I think Tango like
between people within one and two and
now Hi-Fi rush like I think they've
like they've all sudden skyrockets like
over and go as far Tokyo they've really
uh they've created like a wide range of
like interesting unique titles at this
point yeah like I they've kind of become
like a studio that I'm really being
patient too even if I don't like love
all their games I think like
every single time they show up with
something it's like there's a distinct
thing that they're trying to accomplish
yeah so it'd be cool I'm not I'm
personally not ranking on seeing
anything from Tango just because we had
high five rush earlier this year but
yeah I feel like in terms of that bigger
projects I it's gonna be a couple days
I'm gonna be interesting I I agree
they're a fun interesting studio and I'm
very interested to see what they've got
coming up uh in terms of other Xbox big
hitters not anticipating seeing anything
from Halo uh yeah unfortunately three
four three I don't know I feel like
I don't know 343 was sort of gutted by
yeah I know but like
I guess the question is like
does my is Microsoft invested in trying
to present Halo as an ongoing kind of um
Marquee franchise because the end of or
where we're at with infinite doesn't
leave that franchise in a good spot do
they see a future in making Mr Chef
still one of the the icons Halo icons
and if they are if they see a future in
it they really need to say something
that indicates that they're still trying
even if it's repeated you know even if
they're failing constantly with it or
like having successes to some degree and
and like dropping the ball in other
places they've got so much invested in
Halo as an IP and 343 as a studio like
one of their major Studios that they
need to do something to say hey these
folks are still working on something or
we're trying to figure out how to make
um Halo good and all like improve the
performance of it or like restore it to
some sort of kind of prestige
if they don't do that in this show I am
genuinely thinking like is this the end
for Halo like is is are we and honestly
I'm at the stage where I'm like I would
be okay with that like I've had some
amazing times with Halo but like there's
something going on there where it's like
the magic is gone like and it's been
gone for a long time and the attempts to
bring it back have been stumbles in a
way that I think gears is in a better
position than Halo is right now like the
Coalition as a team that picked up a
major Xbox IP
um after it's you know known developers
passed it on has performed way better
with gears then 343 has done with Halo
and maybe it's a case of like them going
let's let Halo go
um we'll double down on Gears I would be
very surprised if they did that like
Master Chief is still a big deal Halo is
still a major property I feel like they
need to say something about that
property
yeah if they don't um I'll be I'd be sad
and a little worried yeah
gears I would love to see
so I'm intrigued to see what uh if they
come out with anything but I think for
me as well you know we got games like
perfect dog which you mentioned earlier
which uh kind of was sort of
2020 they showed that off for the first
time and it was just you know very brief
trailer quadruple quadruple Studio
whatever the hell that means but I would
love to see something from perfect dark
I would love to see hellblade too just
you know these big franchises these big
big games that we know hey that Xbox has
cooking but also that we know you know
people have a lot of interest in and are
just kind of champion in the bit to see
a new hexic yeah
Peggle three I mean that's Microsoft
solitary yeah come on uh I like there's
even other Studios too
um like I know this game wasn't a huge
hit but I really enjoyed or at least
like I like it in concept as we have a
few yeah
right yeah yeah yeah and like hello
neighbor I think that's a game
yeah it's still a Vibe similar Vibe yeah
that's maybe yeah clunky face aesthetic
yeah
um but like we have a few I know it's a
game that was like really not in good
shape when it came out but um having
having played it uh in the past couple
years like it is
first thing immersive sin like I really
do think that game has a lot going on
and I think that studio is like very
still very young and I think they only
have like two games out and like there's
Studios like that that Microsoft owned
that like this seems like an interesting
card that they have in their pocket and
like those are like we already know
about Hellboy too we already know
Perfect Dark spin announce those are the
big games yeah quadruple a again
whatever the hell regardless of what we
see I think the most important thing
that needs to happen and when we come
out of this the theme needs to be they
gave us release dates they gave us a lot
of release dates and they were like
reasonably close together the the uh the
goal was one major release per quarter
for Phil and I think they need to show
that they put in the time and they're
going to execute on that yeah we'll go
three minutes until the Showcase two
minutes now until the Showcase uh we
will be back obviously afterwards uh
we're gonna be doing the Giant Bomb talk
over two but we'll be back afterwards to
dissect all of the big announcements the
boys I gotta ask him two and a half
hours of stuff uh what's I don't know
what's your wild card what's your mad
cap prediction
the legacy of cane Soul Reaver remake by
double fine fine by anyone
anyone except double fine it's never
gonna happen but you know it's you said
wild card and I'm just trying to I went
on Twitter long enough and I've seen
manifesting has got a 50 50 hit rate
sometimes so you know no I'm manifesting
very really works but you know I'm gonna
try I'm that's where I'm at right now
I'm like I'll manifest a lot of
Attraction yeah Law of Attraction
exactly I'm I am attracted to Raziel so
that's [__] go how about you cat I'm
so lame I just say Legacy came so River
for me please
uh I just this is so boring and I said
this already but like I really
love Wolfenstein I like a lot of
Wolfenstein 3 is so bad uh
but that's
otherwise I can't because I have to say
this but you know
couple years since Psychonauts 2 came
out
we'll find them too what are they doing
been really well I mean yeah
documentary and all this stuff has
recently just gone on the GamePad yeah
like stacking and everything so you know
what I'm saying like there is a nice
momentum behind it would be good at
least you know I mean but it's you know
there's still a small team and I already
find presents one versus one hundred
oh
don't even joke about that man there we
go I love one versus 100 done by double
fine that would be wild and then
would be
good that would be so good so good it's
never happened
so yeah Wolfenstein three you yeah me oh
no uh Dishonored three I mean oh my God
yeah
yeah that would be so good if volcano
would like listen
up it'll be all right
[Music]
no I mean I think just in terms of
stuff like State of Decay which I'm kind
of interested in a little bit but we
gotta rap we gotta go uh we'll be back
afterwards enjoy the Xbox showcase bye
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh we're finally doing this are we
because I was going to make a sandwich
[Music]
okay
let's do it
[Music]
what do I think about heroes well we've
all seen them haven't we swatting about
the place
they're disproportionately high cheek
bones and comically massive weapons
roughing up Bandits because they like to
rough up Bandits don't they living it up
with the common folk every single night
on a day-to-day basis I'll say the true
heroes me someone who's breaking you
ground with fruit with veg on the
agricultural side of things just look at
them not wafting around mythical
creatures
that's what they are
wafters yeah well done you see I'm not
here to slay legendary beasts
I'm here to conquer the vegetable not a
euphemism let's face it the age of
Heroes is over this is the age of
innovation this if you will is the age
of death
one moment
[Music]
this is awkward
yeah
[Music]
oh
World premiere
[Music]
all right
they don't have no message
[Music]
you come to your house and it won't stay
long
you look in the bed and somebody'll be
gone
yeah don't have no mercy
[Music]
shaking bones
it's been a while
so you remember that favor you owe me
what
I'm looking for a creature
huge sneaky
teeth like knives
no
oh hey how about you guys
nobody
not helpful
[Music]
sneaky
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
World premiere
these are dangerous times
at least that's what I hear
the empire
[Music]
[Applause]
they're everywhere
but the world here
belongs to syndicates
I want to survive
I have to play their game
foreign
[Music]
thank you
wherever that takes me
I'm here to offer you a way out okay
get off my ship Jalen
give me a chance
to trust me it'll be dangerous risk it
but if you pull this off you'll never
look over your shoulder again
foreign
[Music]
wow Fable south of Midnight Star Wars
Outlaws Welcome to our first ever double
feature the Xbox game showcase followed
by a deep dive into one of the most
important RPGs ever made Starfield
gaming is the most powerful of all
entertainment it transports it
challenges it connects us and it's just
incredibly and awesomely fun
that is why team Xbox is committed to
building the greatest place to play by
partnering with the most ambitious of
game creators and by unleashing the
power of the Gaming Community enabling
all of us to play the games we want with
our friends anywhere for mobile devices
to PCS to consoles
the lineup we have for you today is just
incredible
these are the works of the very greatest
creative teams from around the world
we made this show for you the largest
most engaged and globally diverse fan
base in Xbox history
you are the heart and soul of Xbox your
passion drives us and you are the
inspiration for The Visionaries whose
games we showcase today
from me and all of the team at Xbox
thank you
this next game is from Thunder Lotus the
award-winning Studio behind Spirit Fair
who've gone back to their combat roots
with an amazing Co-op raid focused
action game that is uniquely theirs
all right everybody it's time
World premiere
[Music]
foreign
guys it's a simple job
just in and out nothing to it
[Music]
everybody hit the floor
foreign
[Music]
World premiere
foreign
[Music]
easy steps
foreign
people don't like you very much do they
sent here to the living lands
by an emperor who couldn't bother to
come himself
to investigate some plague
that seems to be corrupting of their
souls
you want us to trust you
but the truth is
you scare us
the way you fight
the power you will
the secrets you keep
you're either here to save us
[Music]
or destroy us
foreign
what are you gonna do with it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
the most notorious Tavern on melee
Island
wall-to-wall Rogues and scoundrels
so tell me which ship is right for you A
big ship a luxury ship a ship with just
a splash of je ne sais quoi the legend
of Monkey Island you mean Governor
guybrush but freeport's not set foot out
of that Mansion for almost a year
hey what do you think you're doing I
told you no autographs though I see you
have a meet and greet ticket and I guess
it's not every day that you get to meet
the mighty pirate guy Rush 3-pood The
Legend of Monkey Island
the Chuck has turned the memories of
this island into a prison for guybrush
well well what do we have here
you need this
[Music]
beans may be very different from the sea
of Thieves you know
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
ER here speaking to you from our
performance capture stage at Ninja
Theory where we have just wrapped our
shoots for sanua Saga hellblade 2. when
we first showed gameplay for hellblade 2
it was a look at some of the games
cinematic and immersive action where
senoir faced off against a gigantic
troll on the Icelandic coastline
today we're taking you deeper into
Central
her unique perspective on the world and
the intimate Journey that awaits you in
senua Saga what you'll see today is all
captured by the team on Xbox series X
she can feel them
slipping through her soul
following the threats of her mind
she's here to find them
I want to hide
she needs her help with a promise
let us never so simple is it
wisdom has a prize
there's always a part of you that
changes
a part of you that darkens
and a part of you that dies over there
about the pool
I can feel them feel them everywhere The
Lost Ones they are watching us
I can
smoke
to this guy to happen it's time to find
out how can we make it happen it's time
to find
anyone it's time to find out what are
they waiting
what are you waiting for I'm here
watching
more than one
where are they where are you what do
they want I don't like I'm scared
all right
their eyes everywhere can flip boring
into
which
is awesome what do you want me to do
not anymore
are you ready for what you'll find here
hope we will find
what if it's all for nothing
[Music]
they are waiting there is
us
[Music]
be in your mind your voice
foreign
[Music]
those you have saved
or those you led to death
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God
oh
surf's up dude yeah dude
[Music]
Instagram
foreign
[Music]
pluck from post-atomic flight the fruit
of years of prudent progress and
determined reclamations and 15 million
dwellers worth of keen imagination from
the heart of West Virginia to the depths
of the pits
[Music]
no matter if you roam alone or spend
your time with friends you'll find a
home in Appalachia where the good times
never ends there are relics to uncover
from a time before the war along with
loads of friendly folks to meet and
enemies Galore our world is always
changing greater funnels are overthrown
as we embark on Expeditions into
thrilling new unknowns yes from
Appalachian settlements to Nuka World on
tour you're never short on things to do
on places to explore I think you've seen
it all hey well how about this pack your
bags for an escape of Epicurean Bliss
put your rad shield on and fix your hair
up pretty because we're headed for the
boardwalk of Atlantic City
so there you have it now you know
there's a million ways to make the
Wasteland your waste home and when you
hear Adventure calling when you're
looking for some kicks answer the call
answer
the call of all 76.
play it now with Xbox game pass
World premiere
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
foreign
[Music]
Motors historic commitment to
Performance is embodied in two of its
iconic Brands Chevrolet and Cadillac
the V series dot R elevates Cadillac's
competitive Spirit to a whole new level
with its thunderous V8 and Hybrid Power
the legendary Corvette has been a
celebrated Champion for decades
the all-new Chevrolet Corvette eray
continues that tradition
General Motors is proud to usher in a
new era of competition with the
innovators behind the new Forza
Motorsport
Forza Motorsport and General Motors are
pairing their strengths in technical
excellence and sophisticated modern
design
to take bold steps into the future and
bring that experience to gamers
I'm thrilled to welcome the cadillacv
series.r and the Corvette e-ray to the
home of competition
[Music]
I know you're ready you've got this
let's tweak the car's performance for
the next one
amazed
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
that was your best lap yet
this is my timeline
[Music]
foreign
betrayal
enjoy this
ambition
and courage
I am the one who knows
thank you
for perhaps the first time in my
unending
which I feel this method from Faith's
flow
of forces move against me hungry or
forbidden knowledge
hidden
a secret that threatens to unravel
reality itself
foreign
[Music]
Toronto is under attack
no sector
the difference about no sector this time
they've taken over most of the city and
the rounding up omnics they need our
help
are answering Vincent's recourse
and we have so much to teach them
[Music]
we can stop no sector maybe we can save
the city coming through
it's been a while as if I didn't have
enough problems already
I hate to interrupt the moment but I'm
picking up reports of more attacks in
other cities
it's a fight day one I say let's give it
to him
[Music]
engaged Target
time to create things with bullets
friends
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go shall we do this together fight
with me engages watch me
I saw that not bad
thank you
what is this place it looks like we're
in a palace what's going on who are
these people no idea but if they're
attacking us our only choice is fighting
back hey look over there
can you get us out of here so you're
telling me your thieves who steal hearts
and you just happen to stumble into this
world
the rebel core will always help the
Phantoms just as the Phantom thieves
have helped the Rebel Rebel never forget
that we're United Force who can rely on
each other
grateful to have been made my subjects
but you're just a matterless little
friends
unfortunately returning will be no easy
feat
somewhere deep inside I know you realize
things can't go on like this
so will you take a stand beside us yeah
let's show them what we got
Empire
[Music]
Humanity has always hunted for knowledge
in the unknown
the Wonder is
not that the field of stars is so vast
but that we have measured it
[Music]
thank you
we're all here because we're committed
to the biggest question of all
what's
[Music]
you're part of constellation now
part of our family
[Music]
we do not fully understand all that is
at work here no finer group in the stars
to be unraveling this mystery
thank you
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for another great
secret the universe is asking us to
unravel
human settlements throughout the Galaxy
could be at risk
[Applause]
we are not stopping whatever lies at the
end of this road
will change Humanity
forever
[Music]
This Is Where We Belong
World premiere
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
World premiere
foreign
[Music]
come over to
you
[Music]
foreign
all right
I'm very excited to be returning his
Johnny silverhead in the upcoming
expansion for cyberpunk 2077.
Phantom Liberty
this new adventure reunites Johnny and V
on a dangerous spy mission and
introduces Idris Elba as secret agent
Solomon Reed
it's really amazing to share the screen
with you Idris it's cool to be a part of
this game with you man
um as a player
you'll get to visit Dogtown an
unexplored part of night City and rescue
the president of the new United States
of America
expect a massive expansion twists
secrets and plenty of stuff to do
I know the team at CD projekt Red just
keeps raising the bar when it comes to
telling cinematic stories and video
games and I really can't wait for you to
play it on Xbox series X and S
but enough talking I'm guessing you want
to see for yourself and so it is my
honor and pleasure to give you and
introduce the official trailer for
Phantom Liberty
there's got to be a way out of this
[Music]
my name is Songbird
I'm an nus intelligence analyst I know
about the bomb taken in your head
and I can save your life
what's the catch
I need you to get to Dogtown
attention all job Town residents
president managed to crash through space
Force One into our humble District man's
got a thousand and one reasons to want
Myers as a hostage sleeper agents
time to wake them up
so nusa is tossing us back into The Fray
huh stay sharp we're in the Wolves then
now
get Myers out of there time to evap
her safety is the top priority
catch us out here we're dead wait hear
that God almighty
Adam
someone ratted us out
you know the treason ain't never black
and white
it's a charade V wherever she goes
people get hurt bodies dropped just one
word Songbird promised me
care
situation has changed I need to know if
you're with me illusion of Freedom draws
in the desperate take your truth be come
on got iron in your head gotta put it to
someone's head pull the trigger
thank you
do anything and do it soon I'll die
[Music]
foreign
World premiere
[Music]
boys
you know
[Music]
foreign
cities have fallen
our people's only means of survival is
to seek Sanctuary here
in the belfry
you must explore this world
finds the origins of this evil
[Music]
and bring hope
back to our people
[Music]
foreign
World premiere
[Music]
foreign
this city is a miracle of progress a
finely tuned
delicately balanced machine
[Music]
but it only takes one rebellious little
gear
to ruin
everything
[Music]
if you resist my rule
if you alter our past
if you threaten what I have built
there is nowhere in space or time where
I will not destroy you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no what did I do
any last words
therefore my friend puts one in your
scout
[Music]
thank you all for joining us today is a
special day for me and the team
I'm excited to see 11 games showcased
from our first party Studios we opened
with Fable from playground games which
will bring the franchise into the modern
era while staying true to its British
style and humor
compulsion and an exile shared their
first original experiences since joining
Xbox with south of midnight and
Clockwork Revolution
and we are thrilled at how a vowed is
shaping up for release next year from
the RPG Masters at obsidian
in addition to about our Studios will
deliver hellblade 2 an all-new Microsoft
flight simulator power born and More in
2024.
later this month players can look
forward to Elder Scrolls online necron
and sea of Thieves Monkey Island
as we look to Holiday we will launch
star field and Forza Motorsport both
built for Xbox series X S and PC
we are also honored to share 14 games
today from our creative partners
like Star Wars Outlaws from Ubisoft
massive in collaboration with lucasfilm
games
33 Immortals from Thunder Lotus kunitsu
gami path of the Goddess from Capcom and
more Persona games coming to Game Pass
thanks to our continued partnership with
Sega Atlas
I'd also like to congratulate the studio
zero team on metaphor re fantasio it's
great to be able to Premiere what is
next from the creators of persona here
in our showcase we are focused on
putting our players and game creators
first in everything we do
no matter if you choose to play on Xbox
PC or over the cloud all gamers are
welcome here at Xbox
when it comes to our consoles we have
heard your feedback on two fronts first
we have significantly increased our
supply of Xbox series X making it easier
for fans to find globally
we know you've wanted more storage with
Xbox series s and I'm excited to share
we have some news there as well
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
and now for the one more thing you've
all been waiting for
prepare for the most comprehensive Deep
dive we've ever done for the biggest
game we've ever built so sit tight and
enjoy Starfield Direct
[Music]
air constellations
hey everyone thank you so much for
joining us today and welcome to Bethesda
game studios you know we've been so
lucky over the decades to make the kind
of games that we love here and that's
thanks to all of you from the Elder
Scrolls The Fallout we love creating
these worlds and playing in them just as
much as you do and throughout all that
time we'd often talk about and dream up
the space game what if we could take
that feeling of being who you want to be
and exploring a new world but set it in
space where you weren't really Limited
in where you could go or what you could
do and that is Starfield obviously we've
come a long way since then with the
games we've built our technology and all
of us here in the studio we've done so
much together but well we've never tried
to make a game like this today you'll
get to hear from many on the team and
see so much of what we think makes our
game special so let's jump in and take a
look
[Music]
thank you
Starfield is our first new universe in
over 25 years but it's still a Bethesda
RPG through and through where you step
into a new world and you get that
feeling of unlimited possibilities
but this time it's not just one world
it's over a thousand worlds because the
choice of where to go it's not ours it's
yours
and it wasn't until now that we had the
technology to create it
from the rocks at your feet to the
mountains in the distance
to the people and creatures that live in
these worlds
that isn't just a backdrop that moon is
actually there orbiting the planet yes
you can visit it too
our next Generation lighting model uses
real-time Global illumination to light
the world based on the type of star and
the makeup of the planet's atmosphere
[Music]
we also have an all-new animation system
and of course you can play it in third
person
and you can play it in first person
we love exploration and rewarding it but
you do explore differently in this game
given its scale
that usually involves exploring an area
you've landed in
you can collect resources
do a mission and maybe even stumble upon
something unexpected
everything
we do love stuff and all of the items
allowing you to pick everything up and
you can view all that in your data menu
this is the hub for everything you're
doing from your skills to your ship your
missions and your inventory we love to
pack a ton of detail in every object
from all of your weapons
to spacesuits
to food we just obsess over the details
and food we obsess over food
when you're done exploring you can walk
back or fast travel to your ship we have
Companions and crew you can take with
you I left vosco here back at my ship
welcome back Captain Howard and he can
even say your name let's head out
[Music]
our mission was to convey the Wonder and
Majesty of space exploration to evoke
the Romance of the golden age of early
space flight and we've been referring to
this approach as NASA Punk this means a
design language where the tech is
advanced yet still looks grounded and
relatable for us it's a contrast that's
where the visual interest is obviously
the NASA which is the rigid pod function
over style and then Punk which is all
about Style
visual style coming through in your ship
your ship is your home for you and your
crew and like many of the spaces in our
game it has a slightly retro and analog
touch a bit of Lo-Fi rather than sci-fi
where everything is well used worn and
lived in alrighty what's the plan
captain
this is your star map it starts with the
planet you're currently on
you can see all of its info and
resources you can choose a landing spot
or fast travel to known locations
backing out further you can view all the
planets in the system obviously the game
is big and it's here you can see planets
that have key locations missions or life
on them versus the many planets that are
Barren but resource heavy
zoom out even further to see all the
systems in this part of the Galaxy
a course to ones that are light years
away this uses your ship's grab drive to
fold space and jump to these systems and
you will need to upgrade your shipping
skills if you want to jump to the most
distant ones but for now we'll plot a
course to the Alpha Centauri system
where we can find the city of New
Atlantis
welcome to UC space maintain your
current course while we scan your ship's
cargo
[Music]
scan complete
a cleared for landing at new Atlantis
[Music]
as soon as you land in a city like new
Atlantis your eyes are guided upwards to
just these boundless vast buildings
it's the biggest city we've ever made
not just in size but also in the amount
of custom art crowds and quests
so the main focus when we're designing a
city is obviously what supports the
story we try and tell as many small
stories as possible this is a colony war
memorial it's a few moments of gameplay
that make the space feel like it's full
of real characters that are going about
their day-to-day lives it's paralyzed if
you really stop and think about it buddy
it's coffee it's also where your
adventure with constellation begins
[Music]
welcome to Constellation we have a lot
to talk about by the time you meet them
constellation is sort of seen as this
mythical group most people don't even
know they exist anymore they're the last
true explorers in the galaxy and they're
trying to find the answers to some of
Humanity's biggest questions the
so alien and I'm certain one of them
reached out and spoke to you
the artifact if you could place it on
the table here
definitely an Eclectic cast of
characters you've got Sarah Morgan the
ex-soldier and adventurer now
constellations leader Mateo the
Theologian who believes that there's
definitely something else out there Noel
the gifted scientist and Sarah Morgan's
Protege and Walter a very successful
businessman in the settled systems and
constellations financier anything goes
as long as you have the money there's
also Vlad the ex-pirate Sam Coe the
former Space Cowboy and Barrett you know
what I hate about these Pirates
completely resistant to my otherwise
irresistible charm
the journey you take with constellation
is just the first of many you'll embark
on the settled systems is home to all
kinds of different stories people and
Adventures for you to uncover
[Music]
the United Colonies is where you'll find
new Atlantis the first major human
settlement in space
people who live here value law
discipline and the legacy of humanity
they consider themselves the true
children of Earth you ever think of
joining up with a Vanguard help the
United Colonies even get your UC
citizenship new Atlantis isn't the only
city within the United Colonies
the city of Sedonia on Mars to this day
serves as the largest Mining facility
for the United Colonies
beyond the United Colonies reach you
might find yourself in a much more wild
and independent Coalition of star
systems
this is Freestar Collective space
up at all on the Freestar Collective is
Aquila City
Stone route inn is an Aquila City
fixture
Ranger relies on judgment and intuition
to do what's best for the people
neon started out as a fishing platform
but is now known throughout the several
systems as a pleasure City where almost
anything goes if you've got morality
issues this definitely isn't the job for
you
reunion is hiring the best and brightest
of today for our future tomorrow
everyone has been chewed up and ground
up by Neon try not to get yourself
killed all right
outside the bounds of civilized space
there are still plenty of unclaimed
systems to explore but these areas are
also home to the most hostile factions
in the galaxy
all heathens shall be made Dust In Time
a new face this is the face of a brave
Runner here to challenge the Red Mile
they think the Galaxy is theirs they are
wrong it belongs to the Crimson Fleet it
always has
[Music]
in Starfield we're pushing our cities
and settlements further than we ever
have before it's all there waiting for
you a slice of Humanity's future
so ready to get out there
throughout the Galaxy there are so many
things to see and stories to experience
the most important story is the one that
you tell
I'm the type of person who spends hours
in character creation and I think people
are going to be really excited when they
see all of the improvements we've made
one of the biggest overhauls was done
through our character generation system
we scanned a wide range of faces from
different age groups and ethnicities and
by mixing and matching out that data we
were able to create a highly detailed
and diverse characters
use that exact system to create all the
characters and NPCs you're going to see
in the game so any character you see
almost always is a character you could
make yourself
hey come on come on okay take it easy
you were out cold uh no physical damage
mentally the jury's still out
you know who you are new recruit for
Argos extractors ring any bells
any of this look familiar
[Music]
start your character creation Journey as
though you're cycling through employee
records you'll pick from a lineup of 40
presets and that'll be your starting
point
quick as you want
system has more to offer than ever
before
[Music]
the simplest character generation system
ever had we let the player get as close
as possible to make whatever they want
with
with various facial morphs you can blend
together the thermostatic and makeup
blemishes scars piercings teeth settings
it's a lot but I think it's the most fun
to use
character creation is more than just how
you look this is also where you start to
decide who you want to be that's where
backgrounds come in
backgrounds give you a bit of backstory
and starts you out with three basic
skills from Chef to Dusty you know the
crew still has a betting pool about
which restaurant critic you must have
crossed to wind up here what's great
about backgrounds is you never know when
yours is going to come in handy you
could be in the middle of a fancy
restaurant talking to some guy and
suddenly you learn he needs a beast
hunter to help track down a monster fine
I probably should stick to professionals
anyway given what happened the last time
we're also giving you the option to
customize your build even further by
letting you pick up the three traits
traits are completely optional and they
come with their own advantages and
disadvantages you could choose to meet
your biggest fan
really really
you he'll join your crew and he'll give
you gifts if you're willing to put up
with this constant commentary I can't
believe I get to stand near you
breathing the same air I've got to have
every molecule my favorite trait is kid
stuff you have to pay some credits to
support your parents but they're very
sweet and it's really fun to go visit
them honey we got ourselves a visitor oh
my God I came across some hostile
zealots in space but because I had
chosen a treat that made me the same
religion as them I was able to get by
without any issues
great one that gives you a damage Buff
when your health is low but mercenaries
will randomly show up and try to kill
you
no matter what you choose there will be
plenty of ways for you to tell your
story and if you want to remove a trait
there are ways to do that too lot of
view
it's a feast Feast for the eyes off we
go
get on your own
[Music]
oh
once you've built the perfect character
that's when your journey can really
begin
we took what we loved about skills and
perks from our previous games and put
them together to create an all-new skill
system
each time you level up you get a skill
point which can be used to unlock or
rank up skills
ranks are unlocked by completing
challenges associated with that skill
[Music]
challenges become increasingly difficult
as you work your way to higher ranks
with our five different skill trees and
four ranks per skill there's a lot to
choose from
oh because it lets you know aliens
boost pack out of the gate I'm boost
back and everywhere
xing out my physical tree so I can get
neuro strikes and just punch my way
through combat
that one's a lot of fun
invest in the skills that suit your play
style
very much a stealth player so I'm out
there pig-pocketing everyone
a favorite part about being stealthy
slowly creeping through vents like
you're in a movie
and then jumping out and swinging on
people
whenever possible I like to talk my way
through situations is there is off
limits
fine I'll issue you an access card I'm
more of a run and Gun player
I like doing a death from above thing
where I boost pack over guys and I throw
landmines at them
I like blowing stuff up
[Music]
exploration is a key aspect of all our
games
Starfield there are full star systems
with new life resources and Adventures
[Music]
our team worked hard to strike a balance
between fun and realism we studied data
from NASA and a multitude of other
sources to help us make the world feel
believable
from the way we approached planetary
atmospheres to the way we place biomes
based on the planet's distance from the
Sun
once we had created a grounded world we
could start looking at all the things
that make that world fun
when you leave a planet and head into
space
you'll be navigating asteroid Fields
having chance meetings with interesting
strangers dog fighting in space and
exploring derelict ships
it's all out there
ultimately it's about rewarding your
curiosity because whether it's on the
surface of a planet the alleys of a city
or the vastness of space you never know
what you'll find
foreign
space exploration is possible thanks to
your ship your ship is almost like
having another character or home you can
make all your own I think you'll be
blown away by the amount of stuff you
can do
and buy a ship I'm sure you can find
something you like customize and upgrade
that ship
and hire a crew to keep it up and
running
[Music]
and it all starts in spaceports
every Spaceport has a ship technician
where you can purchase sell and modify
ships anything I can help you with
maybe you start off with a speedy
fighter that's perfect for bounty
hunting
then you might round out your ship
roster with a hulking space braider to
run cargo missions or even do a little
smuggling
for now though we're going to take our
starting ship the frontier
and make some changes
you can customize and upgrade everything
you see here
and you have two ways to do that
you can quickly upgrade individual
systems like your weapons or Shields or
you can deep dive and enter the
shipbuilder mode here you can change
anything from the systems to the look
and layout
adding a new habitat module can give you
more room for crew
adding cowling can change your ship's
overall silhouette
an improved grab Drive allows for longer
distance space jobs
you can even fully customize your paint
job to get the exact look you want
the parts you choose to build with don't
just affect your ship's stats
they'll also affect what you can do
inside your ship
you can have modules for crafting
or for storing and displaying your
weapons
starfield's in-game ship manufacturers
bring their own look and feel to every
piece of your ship
from living quarters to cargo holds mess
halls and control rooms
our modified Frontier is a practical
ship but with a little creativity your
ship can look like almost anything you
want
it's a bit odd but one of my favorite
ways of customizing ships is a
I make them look like animals
[Music]
the HMS platypus as I called it
where I had like a giant tail to it
[Music]
and we've done spiders we've done mix
so it's really whatever your imagination
is
and while you can build your home Among
the Stars the way you want to you're
probably not the only person who will
call your ship home
[Music]
ready to lift off when you are captain
engines ready
Frontier is fueled and ready captain
some of the members of constellation can
join you on your journey these
companions can serve on your crew and
they'll always be there when you travel
we'll be traveling together until we
either find an artifact or this lead
Runs Dry
each companion comes with their own
valuable skills for your ships and
outposts
as well as unique quest lines eventually
some friendships might blossom into
romance I don't know that I've ever
really loved anyone
except you and if you're looking for a
little extra help on your ship you can
always hire additional crew at
spaceports got any room on your ship for
someone like me
you'll also meet potential crew members
out in the world still think there might
be a spot for me on your ship I gotta
get off this rock
assign crew to your ship or outposts and
their unique skills will affect how they
run
and just like companions most crew
members can lend a hand in the field
take Bosco for instance
these designed around the cool basics of
the NASA machine please avoid getting
shot you might die I still want to give
it almost a humanoid personality so I
elongated the limbs this tends to make
him feel more human-like and give him a
little personality it is a shame
exploration requires so much bloodshed
using the shipbuilding tools and crew
selection features in Starfield you'll
be able to build and Captain the ship of
your dreams
[Music]
and now let's take to the sky
foreign
we're putting you in the cockpit of your
very own spaceship and telling you that
you can do pretty much anything and that
is really cool for us as Developers
this flight should be exciting and
dangerous and you should feel like
you're in complete control every step of
the way
we've extended that sense of control to
ship combat it's not about just hitting
your triggers to fire your weapons
complex dance between your piloting
skills and our power allocation system
boosting power to your engines will make
your ship faster
powering up the ground dries will
shorten the amount of time it takes
before you can make a jump
and moving your power to your weapons
and shields means you're ready for a
fight
you should always be on your toes
because you're not alone out there
[Music]
unlocking the targeting control system
skill will allow you to zero in on
specific subsystems of the ship you
target
[Music]
after destroying an enemy ship you can
loot The Remains from your cockpit
you can always turn any ship that
engages you into scrap
okay
but you could also take a more personal
approach by docking with the Enemy
vessel and boarding their ship
once you've taken control of an enemy
ship it's yours
at your Fleet and retrieve it at any
Spaceport
but space is way more than fighting for
your life
just like when you're PlanetSide there
are plenty of sights to see and stops to
make on the way to your next adventure
like these massive star yards
Walk The Halls talk to the crew maybe
get talked into buying a whole new ship
a civilian in moistayat let's see about
getting you a proper ship one worthy of
you maybe you'll dock with a gigantic
Battleship like the UC vigilance
or rub elbows with the Galaxy's wealthy
Elite on a cruise ship fit for the Stars
there are plenty of personal encounters
to be had as well you can hail any ship
you come across to trade swap info or
maybe even commit an act of piracy let's
do this
when I'm playing I generally go crazy I
definitely go like the more piracy
routes I want to take over ships I'm
going to board ships I'm like this is
now mine I steal all these sandwiches
and put them you know in my cargo hold
that I have specifically for sandwiches
I don't want to play the hero but I want
to go out and just start taking things
from people as quickly as possible
some strangers might be looking for a
little human Connection in the darkness
of space
[Music]
I just finished picking up some
some of the best moments are the ones
you discover on your own
the thing I love most about Starfield is
that it is a Bethesda game through and
through
about going to strange new places
meeting interesting people and getting
sidetracked on zany Adventures then
realizing two hours later that you're
involved in a completely new story
you'll
to leave Earth that DNA is so present
here it's in our Random Encounters it's
in our handcrafted quests
and it feels so cool to play it and just
make your own path in this universe
there are over a thousand planets out
there just waiting for you to visit
we want you to feel like explorers
breaking ground on new planets exploring
every inch of a mostly untouched Galaxy
[Music]
we want you to feel hopeful we want you
to feel the sense of awe and wonder
sometimes a little fear
we're giving you a massive playground
and a ton of toys and just setting you
free
[Music]
everybody we've shown you so much stuff
but we thought we'd just take a little
break and show you something a little
bit different you know we put so much
detail into our game worlds and we love
the opportunity to bring that into the
real world with our Collector's Editions
and for this game we've done a watch it
is the constellation explorers watch
this is the watch that you actually get
in the game that acts as part of your
HUD where it's the compass and then
environmental information it connects to
your phone to give you notifications and
other information and we've also
designed this really cool case that it
comes with eastvan
yeah we really took as much care and
designed as cases we did to watch our
attention to detail in the game totally
translates to this inspired by the cases
that the astronauts used during the
Apollo era to bring back samples from
the moon it's got the intricate locking
mechanism authentic heavy comes with a
constellation patch native strap and the
overall functionality and believability
of this as something that would exist in
the world in the Starfield universe
going hey take this you'll find it very
useful out there and it even tells the
time
we actually have something else now that
we're part of Xbox we get to work with
the amazing people on the Xbox Hardware
team and together we have created this
custom limited edition Starfield
controller it's awesome it is now you
know our favorite controller we love
this because it's inspired by the actual
controls of your spaceship
and not only that
we've created the first ever custom
headset with Xbox and this is a perfect
pairing with that controller
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
in every one of our games we always put
so much care into all those little
details that breathe life into our
worlds
but Starfield isn't just a Bethesda game
studios world it's a Bethesda game
studios Galaxy
so why go this big with Starfield
because we want to give you freedom on a
galactic level
freedom to experience both the exciting
planets
and The Quiet Ones
scanning a planet before you land is a
great way to get a sneak peek at the
available resources you can use for
crafting building and customizing I
think what's cool about this whole
system that we we generate the planet
itself as a procedural content but the
handcrafted content itself comes as the
player explore
our system builds a planet as the player
approaches it and we stitch together
luck of terrain after that we have the
system that adds interested in locations
for the player to explore creatures to
encounter
or and plans to pick up
it allows us to add that touch of
environmental storytelling that Bethesda
is known for
teachers have been disrupting our
experiments their habitat isn't far from
here if you could take care of them for
us we would be in your debt so even if
your friends were to visit the same
planet that you had you would have a
different story to tell
oh
it's completely up to you how you want
to interact with each planet whether you
want to explore and see what you can
find
Harvest resources and be on your way
or simply take in the views
with the help of your scanner you'll
chart the Uncharted and discover exotic
wildlife
if you have the skills you can even
figure out that certain creatures and
plants you can build an outpost and
produce resources from those plants and
animals you can get experience and
rewards for fully surveying planets and
fully surveying a whole system
[Music]
we were concepting these creatures we
really wanted to think of them as
natural to the environment we didn't
want alien monsters we wanted native
wildlife
something you've never seen before
when it comes to our exteriors when the
sun moves all that light is calculated
in real time through the atmosphere
our biggest goal for lighting with
Starfield was to make the game feel more
filmic to use lighting and color to
really make it feel more cinematic
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
after some exploring you can find a spot
to set up a base camp
outposts can be built almost anywhere on
any planet and the habitat modules come
in all shapes and sizes filling all
different purposes you can even live in
them assign crew and companions to work
at your outposts for added bonuses and
set up extractors to harvest resources
while you're away
something cool we have this time is we
have a new fly cam where you can toggle
between on foot building or you can now
use a top-down isometric camera which
helps plan out larger parts of the
Outpost and placing those larger halves
so that way you can really plan your
structures and what the overall feel of
your Outpost is and then when you're on
your feet you can really decorate and
fine-tune things much easier
[Music]
foreign
and research stations in your Outpost to
utilize any resources you find or
already have
mod your weapons to adapt them to your
playstyle different weapon sites and
Scopes larger magazines a selection of
grips and barrels different ammunition
like Explosive Rounds
all you stealth players out there will
surely need a suppressor
also choose to go Hands-On with melee
weapons
it's always a delicate balance between
like what's realistic what SIM and
what's Hollywood and I think we sort of
err on the side of like what's fun for
the player
with Starfield we've completely
overhauled our combat
it's more Dynamic the animations are
more fluid
it just feels great
we probably have more mods and more
weapons in this game than I want to say
any other game we've done before there's
a lot of variety
upgraded gear is just one of the many
factors to pay attention to when
engaging in combat you may need to
switch things up based on your
environment
gravity is different for each planet and
boost packs are excellent for getting
around
and for giving you an edge in combat
sometimes you'll even feel like you're
flying
[Music]
zero gravity environments pose a
different challenge firing a ballistic
weapon in zero g will actually push you
backwards
energy weapons on the other hand offer a
more stable shooting experience
we also have mag weapons
these are high-powered electromagnetic
induction ballistic arrays each Barrel
has its own targeting laser and can dish
out some serious damage
get up close and personal with your own
two fists or you like more compact
weapons like pistols and submachine guns
or maybe you prefer something bigger
starfield's got you covered
[Music]
foreign
thanks again for being with us today we
are just so grateful that you've taken
the time and spent it here I know there
was probably a lot to take in there's a
lot to the game even more than we could
show here you know as we play it we're
always sharing these unique and special
moments that only a game like this can
bring when I think about what makes it
special it really is the people here
this game is a reflection of the
incredible and passionate team that made
it all of them putting something special
of themselves into it so let's hear some
of their favorite moments
I love the way that our final
combination of all the new tech has come
together to create some of the most
beautiful sunsets and sunrises we've
ever had in any of our games I love the
creatures the exploration every biome is
different the word that comes to mind is
vast
I like to use our photo mode to take
Rockstar photos
I just love that constant feel of
Discovery and wow I can't believe that
there's more here I'm most excited about
our Outpost Building Systems
my favorite part is every time you step
out on a planet it's a unique experience
I spent all this time building your ship
and you see it on the landing pad these
things are gigantic it's the kind of
thing that you just can't get anywhere
else there's something about seeing a
tower over in the distance and going I
know the gravity's low here I think I
can make that jump my favorite part is
biomes spaceships audio design planets
the day night cycle those details matter
to me diplomacy exploration Freedom the
ending basket obviously I love the robot
so much the incredible amount of Worlds
we created sniper rifles come on lever
action rocket launcher brain sprout
I love but some people might find creepy
and that's right bam
the thing that I enjoy most about the
game is the freedom to be who you want
to be do what you want to do
it's what you've come to expect from a
Bethesda title but on a much bigger
scale
[Music]
on behalf of all of us we can't wait for
you to play Starfield and make your own
special moments
eight minutes ago
[Music]
Google translation
[Applause]
[Music]
Let It Go
[__]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Xbox day uh we just been watching the
Xbox at Starfield showcase there was a
lot to take in
a lot to take I mean one particular game
that had quite a bit to absorb and it
was Fable uh so we're gonna chat about
what we've seen and obviously there is a
bunch of exciting stuff so let's get
cracking I'm Lucy join Again by Kurt in
Davina hi Anton Hussein big freak yeah
the one real uh narrative from this is
there were a lot of big boys and little
freaks yeah and the second trailer is a
big playing ball in the first trailer
there's a big boy there's a big boy
there's a big boy and a little freak
back to back looking up so we got a look
at the new Fable uh with uh Richard yeah
which is surprising I mean I don't know
like it feels like you know
like thinking back to when Fable first
came out yeah you would if you're having
British people you would have a John
Cleese you'd have you Stephen Frye but
Richard iwani
it was pretty easy it makes a lot of
sense it makes a lot of sense yeah in a
world where you needed John Cleese kind
of character I was hoping they just fill
out the entire cast with as many British
actors yeah yeah
take I want an entire side quests that
would be good a fable uh across the land
yeah but what'd you think of it
honestly
I was like shaking at one point and like
it's not even like there was like any
specific game that it was announced that
I was specifically excited for but like
I was like just jazzed to see a series
of like really cool really polished
looking ideas the biggest concern of
course is like all of them are 20 24.
there's no specific release dates for
any of it but even right before we
started slippery shows like there's
certain Studios we haven't seen anything
from like compulsion games that was like
the second game yeah showed
um and so it's just like it was like
validating to see like
some of the things that have been the
Shadows like compulsion I finally see
fables which has like
a way different art style than the
original games and since that's like
more grounded I thought it was awesome
like I genuinely had a great time yeah
yeah I enjoy the show overall I think
what cut said still kind of stands and
it was something that we were concerned
about going in and it pulled through now
is like a lot of the stuff that we saw
was no release date next year that kind
of stuff but having said that you look
at the wrap up at the end by Phil was
clearly the brief was just remind people
what we have coming this year and it's
Starfield yeah and like that alone is
enough to kind of
carry create and carry some momentum
forward which makes a lot of sense but
they also have Forza they also have a
few other small things and new Xbox is
coming out yeah um so I it feels like
I don't think that the uh kind of the
expectation in what we wanted to see uh
how we wanted them to lay out their
roadmap and their Vision was met because
it's a lot of games that we uh know
exist but don't have accurate release
dates but they also create a much better
more encouraging kind of prospect for
the immediate future of Xbox which I
think is like it's not one of those
things where people will look back at it
and be like universally like they nailed
it but I think it's one that people look
back and go they didn't but they did
what they need to do and I think it's a
much better kind of clearing of the
table
um than I expected it to be yeah I mean
I liked it overall I think there was
some really
like just a lot of interesting stuff and
I'm the most excited for it in terms of
oh what Fable or the whole showcase oh
it's a whole show oh yeah I'm excited
about it I thought it was great yeah
yeah I mean thinking about there are
some there's just like a lot of new
stuff in there that was interesting then
we'll talk about but like 33 Mortals
there was a game from don't nod with the
climbing that Capcom one that can just
kind of came out of nowhere but I feel
there wasn't a single game in this
showcase where I felt my uh energy or
excitement dip it was genuinely like I
feel that they curated a very good list
of stuff and again like the stuff that
people are looking forward to the things
that they know about and then yeah it
wasn't expecting to see Outlaws the Star
Wars game yeah yeah I mean and I was
happy to like I at first I was sort of
like as a cinematic trailer like I you
know we'd know this I mean it's the you
know ubisoft's first
um but it was kind of cool to see that
like we are showing gameplay tomorrow
uh so that was like at least assuring
and seeing like Cinemax trailers are
fine like even with Fable it's like it's
a cinematic trailer I'm just glad to see
it exists yeah but it's good to know
that we're at least like going to see it
tomorrow or there's there's it's on the
horizon uh so we still Fable obviously
at the very beginning and then we saw a
brand new one from kaposh games which is
uh south of midnight very cool looking
yeah art style in engine yeah all in
engine another big lad and small
character and with a possum yeah yeah on
the shoulder screen I mean like we know
next to nothing about what that game is
yeah what it means but like it's a very
striking art style and tone piece which
is
a good start for compulsion and it plays
with their strengths they do the same
with their previous game it was like a
striking in Ambience and visual imagery
and iconography and that kind of stuff
so they're clearly are good at that they
just need the gameplay to hold up inside
of the bargain which was something that
you know VIP was a little tricky with
um so the hope is there that that that
element of their team and design has
grown while the other you know visual
stuff remains as cool as it looks in
that game yeah yeah but speaking of
gameplay another jump a little bit no
please do I was gonna say I've probably
not talked too much about Star Wars
because we'll see it tomorrow about
yeah about uh I feel like I was warmer
on a valve than everyone else because
like for me it's you know it plays into
the fantasy [__] that I love and so I
was I just I just a like obsidian you
know with outer worlds uh it's like it's
it's cool to see obsidian like on their
own trajectory being able to do like
more heady uh like big RPG like first
person RPGs
um like
uh uh I mean of course we didn't get
like Fallout New Vegas or any of that
jazz but it's cool to see like their
take on high fantasy uh and I could only
like assume it's going to have that
obsidian like Flavor of writing and like
um which makes me excited for and it's
it's interesting because like I'm more
of a grounded fantasy dude oh you're
that grounded that's a good game yeah
I'm more of a um
if I can't even [__] I can't come
with another word I like Skyrim which is
a specific which is a more uh like a
like I get what you mean yeah
uh but it was cool to see I just like
I'm just I thought Auto worlds were so
cool and like yeah I'm interested to see
if there's like that sort of carryover
of of like the thing that
I'm interested in a vowed I a lot of my
interests or excitement comes from the
pedigree of the studio is coming from I
didn't see anything there that kind of
really distinguished it from other
similar types of experiences or anything
that made me think oh this is why
they're making this game without a world
it was like okay it's that kind of RPG
but it's got a humor to it and it's got
a kind of a writing style that's very
immediately obvious that they're what
they're doing with it whereas this kind
of like being as reductive and and as
harsh as if I had to like it felt
generic like as it felt like generic
Fantasy game which is I almost certainly
think that it's not that but I don't
think we I walked away knowing why I
would want to play that game you know
there was no like the distinct I can't
sum that up in a way in one sentence in
a way that makes it exciting and and
different from a Skyrim or yeah my
answer that would be spells and [__] you
know yeah how many games have spells and
[__] I think it's it's like for me it
comes from the perspective or that I'm
looking at the team like the yeah the
jockey and so I'm not betting on the
jockey I'm betting or I'm not betting on
the horse I'm betting on the job sort of
deal so I feel exactly I see that's
where like the excitement for something
like that comes where it's like sure on
paper certain I agree with you that's
just like if it was probably by any
other Studio Be Like That is a fantasy
game
um but I know at least like you know the
track record of the of the company or
the studio who's making it yeah filled
with interesting it's the pedigree of
the studio which is what I said like
that's why I will pay attention to it as
opposed to write it off completely if it
was some random other studio right
um but it's just I think that trailer
could have been
a little bit more exciting yeah sharper
and shorter and more to the point and
like tell people why they should care
there was nothing at the tell me that
question yeah I'll still play it and I'm
still excited for it uh 33 Immortals the
brand new game from the Thunder Lodge
team uh previously on Spirit Fair top
down action Co-op for
33 players
um I yeah it looks it looks cool
obviously you know the the Hades uh
inspiration or at least you know it's
kind of you know
what a lot of people were saying sort of
in chatting online but like I'm
intrigued by it I wish I mean I don't
know if it'll hit the same emotional no
it says uh spirit fairy did which I
really enjoyed but it looked interesting
I mean I guess again I mean I guess
this this might you know I this is me
just this is assumption assuming you
know like so much of what a lot of these
Studios or I feel like specific to Xbox
and game passes like filling out that
catalog in an interesting way and uh you
know like that I agree it's just like oh
this looks like Hades with the art style
and like aesthetic of a spirit prayer
maybe it won't have
might be
rise out with 33 32 other people who are
worse
um but it was one of those things where
it's like again it was like I really
Spirit fair was like a surprise hit for
me like I did not think I would care
about that game as well
like a Sim game I was like I'll try the
RSO at school and I again it's that like
well the studios took me off guard
before so I'm like willing to see what
their uh what their time says but I you
know on paper it's like again
three three Immortals game possible but
it fills out the Game Pass catalog you
can load it up try it give it a go uh we
also so we talked a little bit about
Persona 3 reload uh we'll come back to
Persona when we talk about the other
game from uh from Atlas
um but see if these so when we were
doing the Giant Bomb
the the rare logo came up and we all
went ever a while yes ever wild then the
Lucas film games came up and we all just
went oh Star Wars
yeah I was like there was the same
roller coaster but I was like typing the
nose and be like all right okay
everybody like oh God they're having
like like [__] like it's like X-Wing
[__] like X-Wing and like seafood yeah
and then I was like Wow uh you became
Crash Bandicoot wow
um but I guess like yeah my quick thing
on that is I think it's really cool CC
thieves do like a massive partnership I
I Feel Like Pirates of the Caribbean
yeah like a year or two ago or whatever
yeah uh and I think it's like really
cool that they just instead of like just
going for the next big IP like Star Wars
they went for a rather I think they've
gone from one that is totally yeah an
incredible match like The Gamers and all
of us yeah but no I mean you know it's
gonna they see these is a very funny
game yeah yeah I wish I could play it
more it gives me intense motion sickness
that's because this is the water is so
realistic yeah I was saying like it
makes a lot of sense like res humor is a
thing that is being leveraged really
well now it was there was a time when it
was like it was people forgot that rare
was the studio made fun and funny games
and and like um
you looked at me I was like uh voice
breaker
you've been screaming all these yeah I
think like matching that humor of rare
with the humor of um Monkey Island is it
makes so much sense that it was like why
didn't they do this sooner it's crazy
that they didn't do this sooner and like
they went all in as well it's not like
oh we've got a guy brush skin it's like
no there's the Chuck is in there they've
like got a full story campaign
characters that are behaving like
little
um Monkey Island weirdos and the freaks
yeah
I'm like
I am almost tempted to like reinstall it
and brave the sickness again because I
love Monkey Island like and it's out
next month yeah exactly uh yeah there
was we were kind of complaining a little
bit that everything was either didn't
have a release date or was it 2024 but
it was really great to see them drop
something like a few things
um like this uh we also got a brand new
flight Sim coming 2024 yeah
um honestly there was a lot going on
there I'm not a flights in person I
actually don't really like flying that
much so but they have hot air balloons
but they've got doomed oh well no that's
it's not for the new one yes no it's for
the current one yes yes see the movie
and watch and play the game uh what was
that tagline but no I mean genuinely
speed boat in your bathtub uh
this is what the director said he said
if you don't see Dune in the theater
it's like having a speedboat a bathtub
and be like that sounds [__] [__] is
sick I'm gonna put a speedboat in my
pants up so that's when I'm gonna play
play simulator in my bad blood my bed
and flying the Dune ship and watch Dune
and on like uh a Game Boy Pocket
um well on a Speed Racer in my bathtub
and experience everything the way he
wanted it to be exactly but another cool
I think that's a really I mean I was
just saying that you know flight Sim
doesn't do anything for me I'm not
really a Sim person other than this
but I was saying when we were on the
giant ball thing that like the way to
get me
is to tie in with stuff that I like a
lot so obviously they did the top gun
Maverick stuff last year uh and now Dune
so hey put a Lord of the Rings
the Eagles big eagle yeah please inflats
him uh what do we think of the hellblade
2 shall we I really like why so
um it's it's really obviously we didn't
get to see
I mean we saw some gameplay stuff I
think it's a very difficult game yeah
and also like I feel like the trailer
that we saw was not as like
action-packed as we probably wanted it
to be we're only more bombast but it hit
what Ninja Theory needs to hit and the
notes that people want out of a
hellblade game which is
ASMR
plenty of that a lot of that but also
like visual imagery they're striking or
moments like you know taking that
fantasy rapper of
understanding mental health and the
issues that plague people that have you
know these kind of like schizophrenia
multiple personality that kind of stuff
kind of angles and psychosis and that
kind of stuff and and presenting that in
a fantasy Universe And as far as that
objective goes I think they nailed it um
the kind of
Prospect of going back to that world is
both exciting because it's I want to
explore it more and see how they
interpret like Norse mythology or
whatever it may be the kind of themes
that they have but also it's
it feels more like oh yeah it's gonna
it's gonna be sad boy times or sad
little times but like it's such a
bizarre experience that or a bizarre
game to be made in this day and age
where it's like we're making a game that
is really important to help you
understand something that impacts so
many people but it's going to bum you
out while you're playing it which is
like oh yeah I'm up for that but also I
don't I would rather not please it's my
it's been my one of my most anticipated
games
since it was announced alongside the
announcement of the Xbox series X like I
have but it's one of those things that
like seeing that trailer is like is a
similar feeling that I think we get that
I've gotten for the past couple years of
scene is like I know like I'm I'm like
I'm ready like there's nothing you can
do to like that won't make me play that
game at this point so like the only
thing I got really excited about is like
the nerdy cinematographer at me is that
like they're like actually making
anamorphic and like using like an
anamorphic simulated lens so like the
like you know the bokeh is a certain way
and I was like
uh and the last time
the last time a game did that where
people got upset was The Evil Within
yeah oh yes patched it out so stick to
your guns Ninja Theory make it
anamorphic the world is ready for it
that's what I'm saying so yeah and we'll
be ready when it comes out in 2024. yeah
that's the thing ever since but I don't
think we had a year attachment to that
it just said 2024 but I mean
yeah it was like when it's ready yeah
yeah uh kind of it's on my personal
highlight of the show like a dragon
infinite
what a Austin Powers ass trailer oh my
God I love this as soon as I saw my boy
Ichiban wash up on the beach I was like
what's up to what's he doing
he was like listening like a dragon this
is a dragon oh my God but no I mean it
looks like it's taking place in Hawaii
or even America and just yeah I'm so
excited get out of this is the first in
the series like I just love the idea of
a Yakuza like spin-off Series where it's
Ichiban just traveling the world and
like on like experiencing culture from a
Japanese perspective but I love the way
that even
play like a dragon in this and there's
the American guys like hey hey hey boy
but like but this is the the one thing
that this trailer didn't show is that
like we know that in this game
kiru is supposed to come back with
different hair but like how and does
that
how is that gonna play into them are
they collectively going at home I mean
like is the man who erased his name
that's like this yeah for that's oh
that's what I understand like yeah
that's basically it's like Curious like
no that's not no no I have silver hair
though I don't have a name goodbye I
erased it I'm a Hawaiian I'm American
uh so yeah so I don't even know what his
name's gonna be now but uh it's just uh
it was definitely like
um amazing yeah I was very excited I
love the trailer yeah also infinite
wealth what a name that is what I would
say like there was a lot of games that
have very forgettable names infinite
wealth is not one of them it's like it
immediately became you will remember one
game name from this show and it is
definitely infinite wealth
infinite well I mean speaking of a game
name that I immediately forgot but the
game looks really cool the trailer was
awesome it was path of the Goddess from
Capital oh yeah which I thought was
onamusha yeah like yes yes
which was sad but also it looks
interesting really cool um looks like a
co-op game well yeah the way the way I
can't believe it's co-op with like oh AI
partner or something yeah like the
camera is positioned in such a way that
made it really feel like it was
but like it's cool you know like it's
cool to see a new IP from a something
like Capcom
um yeah they've been absolutely knocking
it out of the park lately with revivals
of existing IP so this is probably this
is you know
EXO Primal we don't know anything about
oh we don't know if it's good yet
Street Fighter deep down I mean Street
Fighter is great but it's an existing
yeah
um
yeah deep down we don't know where it's
gone
everything else that they're doing is
like we know uh relatively what it's
going to be so this is very an unknown
quantity so I feel like this is a big
moment for Capcom where they've really
raised their profile again
but doing things that you know we know
and this is one of the few games that
they have is like Hey we're going to try
something that you don't know again
and that is like if they can nail that
then I feel like they really cement the
fact that they are back in a big big bad
way
um and hopefully like they've got
another Banger on their hand like
between all the resi games Monster
Hunters Free Fighter the cat back
catalog is doing a lot of work for them
I think they just need to set up some
new ones now I feel like they're in a
position like take a little risk like
yeah that's so many good things like
yeah worst case scenario will remake
another Resident Evil it'll be fine I've
been asking
Devil May Cry remake here it comes
very confused about
which two thing was
yeah it was I think it was that I feel
like if they'd shown that when they
announced that story missions were going
it would have maybe less yeah yeah I
mean it is what they said it was yeah it
is but I don't think maybe it wasn't
communicated well enough at the time but
there was something about having a
visual and kind of still showing people
that there was a lot more story stuff uh
the fact that if you have Game Pass
ultimate you can get like all the new
Heroes that came with OverWatch 2 is
great I'm very into that
um it's it's a confu I think I think it
adds to the confusion a little yeah I
feel like they the disappointment around
them saying that our PV is changing has
been palpable
and this is like further confused it
because it evokes what people think
they're gonna were gonna get out of
the the uh original version of the PVE
right and it's really confusing because
they also it is what they said it was
going to be they were like we're not
doing this elaborate single player
campaign or like a PVE campaign that has
like you know almost a separate kind of
experience with talents and that kind of
stuff but we are taking what we have
built and the ambition for telling
stories and integrating it into the
framework of the OverWatch you know
but when you watch it you're like
a straight up campaign what's going on
and it's like it's very confusing it
also didn't have a like a distinct name
no she doesn't need it
they were just showing off the new modes
and stuff and like that was the main
thing like the hero uh what you call it
the trial modes or whatever oh hero
Mastery and like the new
um other multiplayer gameplay modes and
extra stuff around there but they shot
off a lot of story stuff and it's just
it's just very weird like it's just very
strange confusing messaging and like
Lucy said like if that was there earlier
it might have helped to be like hey we
took out the talent stuff that's gone
but we're still gonna tell this kind of
story that's just like very
yeah I was definitely leaning on YouTube
because like I I loved OverWatch yeah uh
but like I I see you both like as like
the OverWatch
in my life so I was curious because I
was sitting there being like
they thought we weren't doing this
what's going on yeah
uh we had another one uh jewsons
yeah do not have a couple games like
that they have the banishes one which is
kind of looks more in line with what we
traditionally know of us don't know you
know decision based stuff Powers
um yeah this one and they just released
one too yeah it's quietly becoming not
quietly but they're very exciting Studio
like obviously we know them for uh the
hit video game remember me
um and uh yeah
bring it back
um yeah like they are really leveraging
kind of like the success of you know
stuff like life is strange
um to diversify and I think that's a
really smart thing for them to do you
don't want to get pigeon hold and you
know there's probably a team that that
team there who's like we want to do more
than just this specific type of game
because you know the origins you know a
lot of things that kind of put them on
the map is like remember me was an
action game a very interesting perhaps
not a successful action game but like it
had ideas that were really cool though
it's like memory yeah memory and kind of
like remixing and action and platforming
that kind of stuff and that in like
pop off in a major way but when they
found the success of narrative driven
episodic games they kind of lean into
that hard but it meant that
the ideas that they were exploring were
quite kind of predictable you know it
was a very specific template I'm glad
that they're in a space now where ideas
are at the Forefront again and they feel
comfortable enough to explore different
kind of gameplay Styles and and
Frameworks and that kind of stuff so I'm
definitely excited to see what this game
is and how it plays especially if it is
and if it does well it could be an
example of them or a first sign of a
step of them
point out more like that uh next up is I
think another highlight for me uh still
wakes the deep I couldn't ask game as
well oh I like so I love China yeah so
when I saw Chinese room I like stood up
and I was like I don't even know what
this is I wanna I'm here for it and it's
it's uh I I want like they stepped away
from their sort of traditional thing
after the wrestler and everyone's known
to the Rapture they had their one big
game that was like canceled and like
they did like a Machine For Pigs yeah
they had a project they had a rocky yeah
like a few years and they did some
smaller games so it was seeing this like
it looks like a horror game yeah that
they're not 100 as much yeah it really
is I don't even think about it
everybody's going to the Rapture it's a
heart yeah yeah absolutely so I was like
super excited to see like this sort of
return to form for them and it's really
fascinating because
I mean the team if it's the same
leadership team they really know horror
games they never showed it through a lot
of their games but when we did a a
documentary series on Resident Evil one
of the people we talked to was senior no
kind of like personally yeah leadership
role
um Chinese room and the discussion
around Resident Evil it was clear that
they understood survival Horror in a way
that usually you'd expect only survival
horror develops and developers would
know yeah so it's exciting to see that
they're taking something that they are
kind of aware of and and know about and
and are actually making that the main
thing now because that kind of
experience could be really terrifying if
they get it right I thought they really
that's a Kirk game yeah no yeah you know
you're in the other room but I was like
yeah we'll talk about that with care
later
um cyberpunk it was so nice to see piano
again I was thriving especially at the
very end when he was just like when he's
just like
I have to go
uh yeah a really great trailer I think
from Phantom Liberty let me just check
something real quick oh yeah uh from
Friends very I'm excited that it's
coming this year it's coming sooner than
I think we all thought it was uh the
preview uh window is oh can we talk
about it yeah we played it yesterday
yeah
yeah wow it is
Jake has a great preview.com
YouTube channel we played it yesterday
an hour and a half of it yeah a bit of
it yesterday and it it it is pretty
comprehensive like I think that they're
not talking about is how much yeah
Idris Elba and and like uh the new area
but they have this is gonna sound real
cruel and it's gonna sound uh like kind
of maybe a bit click-baity
but I think they finished the game like
this is the game that clearly they
wanted to release
and it shows immediately because the
things that you are like why doesn't
this make sense or why is this so weird
when you play the original and then you
think this is CD projekt Red they know
how to make these games like this is a
very strange decision for them to do
you play this game and you're like oh
you basically had to get it out and this
is the solution to getting out quickly
and now that you're going back to like
build on top this is the original vision
for what you want and it's all kind of
like exemplified by the fact that in the
original trailer they showed off they
showed V leaning out of a car firing a
gun and like it was that cool as [__]
car combat that was not in the game that
they released it is now if you like uh
cars have gone you have car comes guns
were on cars so you can like and there
is a full like five-star police system
again that works where it's like if you
yeah okay if you get like if you get to
the five-star level like match Tech will
come in and drop like crazy like a
powered uh enemies that you have to
fight they made the melee work like
pretty much every major system yeah they
said every major system has been touched
in some way and and it is like the the
swords for example the katanas like it
was so annoying using them they've added
like an air Dash so like you can like
Dash and and sword sword out out and
it's like it feels
like the game that they wanted to make
and the game that we wanted we were
expecting yeah so do you know if those
some of those
the entire game okay yeah yeah yeah so
when I played that I was like I'm
stopping my current playthrough and I'm
gonna wait because it's like they've
reworked the way you upgrade they rework
the way you unlock abilities the skill
trees
you can you can like add when you add
um like cybernetics there's like a bar
which if you go too high it results in
cyber psychosis like it doesn't Edge
Runners and like you're like okay this
is the idea this is what you wanted we
get it now and it like it looks really
we're playing on PC and they'll like
change it tonight and they change it
tonight and all the graphical effects it
was like okay
this is it this is the this is cyberpunk
2077. and um yeah it feels it feels like
obviously we played a small slice of it
yeah so we didn't
to make a little video to kind of set up
the expansion yeah it won't be in the
final game yeah uh and then we played a
little like the first opening part of
the mission and then we had a Time skip
so we missed an hour yeah but then it's
because you don't actually meet Solomon
Reed until quite a little bit further in
so we obviously wanted to be a
solomonary yeah yeah
um
I I feel like we don't know whether it's
gonna hold up the entire way he's like
is it a blood and wine style thing where
you start to finish this Banger or is it
like we saw the very best of of like um
a an expansion that is otherwise okay
but
fundamentally it improves the game as a
whole and it more than anything based on
what I played
it feels like CD project earning the
kind of re-earning the respect and and
the kind of like the the trust that
people put into them after a Witcher
um and it feels like once this is out
and if it's as good as it seems to be
we can be confident in like supporting
that studio again and feeling good about
the projects they make because when they
make something else it will be like okay
they felt it was rough start to
cyberpunk but
they got there in the end and the game
that they put out is actually very very
very good but that's my Hope anyway
that's what that's the Hope like again
like it's preview so who knows that can
that stuff can be manipulated in very
interesting ways but
I'm more confident in cyberpunk the
cyberpunk that we will be getting than
the cyberpunk we go out of the start of
this release which is exciting yep
[Music]
there was a moment where like
City I was like yeah I also had that and
I was like no Sim City 2014 was such a
disaster that I don't think we're going
back there again but uh I said we've
talked about Persona let's talk about
persona so metaphor re fantasio
um from the creators of persona three
sounds like a JoJo character sounds like
a JoJo character
yeah but like so is this the fantasy
game they were working on
Sonic has given me a thumbs up it's the
fantasy game it was it was this project
oh and that makes refund yeah yeah it
makes sense but like I think the initial
reveal made it seem like it would be
more like a dragon questy style like hey
We've Got Elves and [__] but it's like
hey no we've got Persona ass Persona
[__] going on in here ponds it had bonds
like so yeah day system it feels like
what they've done here is like we are
known for persona
we have traditionally made a series
called
shin Megami tensei let's try and see if
we can make another offshoot that brings
some of those things together and
creates a new thing for people to really
get obsessed with and it looks like
everything that you would want out of
like those two kind of uh worlds that
they've created so I'm
I'm excited for anything personally
yeah I mean well no so yeah the uh
episode three reload coming out early
next year uh Persona 5 tactica which Jan
from Giants lost his mind over tiles
tiles tiles he loves it he loves towels
um Persona 3 is my favorite Persona
um and I am so glad that it's coming
back and I hope that it looks like they
have they've given it they look they
finished Persona 5 and was like let's do
that for this game because that game
it's hard to go back to you it's hard to
go back to and especially how because
the leaps between Persona 3 to 4 to 5
are significant like they're huge in
both like design like um style
confidence and and kind of like
narrative as well they're making a lot
of progress in those and
I always wanted them to take those
learnings back to Persona 3 because this
is the one that I really really adored
and that is looking like what they did
and I'm I'm excited for everyone to
experience that soundtrack I'm just glad
that something that there was still a
surprise for Atlas people you know like
it was like it's like it was like you
know there's this moment where it's like
I didn't know it was coming to Xbox but
like Persona 3 remake like reload
whatever it's called like I know an
audience of people
in our office it's like somebody's
changes the cameras I would have lost
their mind we're here I have to say a
couple outside so Michael Heim our our
boy I'm almost he sounds focused on it
he said this uh he's glad that they he
two things did leak because if he saw
Persona 3 uh remake Persona 5 tactica
and then this game back to back he would
have had a heart attack yeah
so much Atlas on stage
yeah and
he's about to making inroads in Japan
and it's paying off they were that time
there was a time when that was making
games for 10 people
it was one one of them yeah
and like it is they're all in this room
it is like it is just wild to see how
far they've come like even as a top tier
developer that they've always been like
I never thought that smt or Persona
would be as big as it is right now and
it's great the same goes for Yakuza like
Sega just
killing it yep
towerborn a brand new game from the team
behind banasaga looked pretty cool I
mean I he manages cities have fallen
into Belfry is all that's left left I
kind of love that stuff but we'll play a
co-op in a never-changing world might
lose me a little bit obviously the
banner Saga such a great and emotional
story but it looked really cool uh
clockweck Revolution though is
definitely more my wheelhouse
one of the surprises of the show I think
I remember if they had already announced
I don't think I've seen that before no I
think that was one of the games that
Phil says we've been making games that
you don't know about so this is the in
Exile uh
a Bioshock in there but it seems like
the lady what was her name again
Ironwood Ironwood she can follow you
through time
or something yeah it's got some wild
stuff yeah so I'm very intrigued to see
how that works out but it looked really
great I straight up like a lot of good
British accents within Exile like what
they do I thought it was like for the
longest time I was like before they even
showed an actual first person gameplay
there was a show in the city I was like
are they just doing a tactical
BioShock Infinite I was like I was like
just like I was just sitting there like
waiting and waiting because just knowing
what this studio does so when I actually
went first person I still was like
dude like wait did they get the Bioshock
like IP I was like what's going on and
then the more and more and more I saw
the more like I was like okay this is
something this is something
different but again it is cool to see a
new IP that like buy an interesting
Studio that usually is known for one
thing that I'll be doing something like
this and like it looks like big like it
looks like it you know yeah like I was
definitely kind of taken back by oh
despite the fact being like what is this
what is this is this not but but yeah
obvious things out of the way I know
time frame
uh Xbox series s so brand new model one
terabyte storage carbon black carbon
black 350 bucks uh something September
first cool a bit of Hardware news that's
definitely yeah I mean like yeah
Starfield is coming up you want to ramp
up production on this uh series X which
is they said that they've done that more
available and then you also want to
create a kind of rejuvenating effect on
the more affordable model for people who
want to download a bunch of games like
it might also be like Starfield is a big
game everyone yeah
we're already prepping the paper yeah
exactly so it makes perfect sense and
people like to buy black consoles
yeah people people like me
it's a star field then
there is a lot that they showed today it
was a beefy presentation very very dense
for my money a little too then yeah came
off to me as quite overwhelming yeah but
I think they did a pretty good job of
saying like they highlighted a lot of
very very cool stuff and I think they
did a good job of kind of saying like if
you want to do this you can if you want
to do that you can
but it's just very difficult to know
where to start yeah I think that's
difficult because like the problem we
had was before we went into it like the
thing I said was I'm not sure what the
core Loop thread is like what is what is
it I assume it's the same thing that you
know Bethesda games have always been
like let's say Quest based RPG and it
seems like that is what this is but then
it's couched in
crazy amount of other things so it kind
of get got lost where it's like what am
I doing this for why am I doing any of
this and like if I just want to sit down
and play for half an hour and do a
couple quests
am I gonna be able to do that or am I
going to be it's gonna it's gonna be
like you need to build a shame also your
plants are dying also that star is
blowing up but also you know you're
being invaded or you need to repopulate
this planet it's like what is the core
but I think that is
almost impossible to lay out in
something like this yeah I'm sure it's
there and it's very clear and it's like
golden path is very obvious and this is
once you pick it up you know exactly
what it is but I didn't see it there and
I also understand why I didn't see it
there it's a big ambitious game my big
thing with this is that um like as a
huge Bethesda freak
um a little freak a little freaky big
freak little freak I'm a big freak
um it's like it was interesting like I
admittedly like started gloss like just
you know it's just glazing over
information at that point because
there's so much to it but I like my take
I was already I'm already gonna play the
game obviously but like the takeaway was
like you know Skyrim is a game that has
lasted 10 years and like it just keeps
going and going and going and it's like
Starfield feels like a game they're
building for 10 years yeah but the one
the other thing I really really
appreciate is that this is a game that's
like
it's good to see a single player game
being built for a 10-year experience
that isn't going to be a games of
service that isn't going to be like it's
it just feels like we're going to get a
big big old big game and like you know
I'm hoping this idea like of building
ships and farms and all that jazz like
you know similar to Fallout for whether
you're ability like builds like bases
and towns like stuff I didn't do any of
that oh that's good that's right people
did oh yeah yeah so I'm probably gonna
build the ugliest worst ship that just
works like I don't I'm not gonna care
it's my little disaster yeah
um same with whatever house I build it's
going to be well actually I did get
pretty serious about my family and
Skyrim
um uh my family in Skyrim yeah and and
uh I adopted two kids I got a skeever
for one of them um
uh they have a room filled with sweet
rolls um I was obsessed with the dev who
said that she just went on sandwiches
she would just raid other people
I was like I'm gonna become a sandwich
Merchant in space but yeah so the thing
that this reminds me of in a lot of ways
and it's a weird kind of point of
comparison but it makes sense in my head
is like
it feels like the GTA online
where it's like they build a thing that
is so big that they just keep adding to
it I mean first three expansion already
benefit exactly I feel like GTA online
is a huge runaway success it makes
an ungodly amount of money and the
foundation of it is when it first came
out people were like this sucks
and then rockstars went in and just kept
adding to it and by the time they were
done like they're not even done by the
time they got to a point where people
were paying attention it was like this
is an incredible like all-consuming
experience where you can be a weirdo
Street Thug or a manager club or
whatever it may be and it feels like
this is the goal and the intent for
Starfield as well but the Baseline is
going to be a much higher quality so
people come in and a lot of that stuff
is already there and then the next 10
years gonna be like hey we added 100
000 more ship uh kind of icons or like
ship parts for you to make something
crazy oh we put
a new planet here and it's got this kind
of vegetation and that kind of stuff and
these weird little creatures and etc etc
and I feel like the 10-year plan thing
is is gonna definitely pay off yeah I
mean I was I was impressed by it and you
know as we said now pre-show I saw the
first trailer I was like wow I'm gonna
play that yeah and so
I I was very surprised at how good it
looked I agree yeah I agree I mean
there's you know there is a certain
style you come to expect with Bethesda
game Studio games sandpaper textures on
everything everyone's looking a little
bit more angular
um but no I thought it looked really
good I'm really intrigued by the the
constellation
um as a group that you join and like
that being the thing that I assume
punts you into space and kind of do your
exploration but like I'm also just kind
of excited for you
like a non-online sort of just chill
maintenance sort of game where I just
have a little farm or I go explore and I
go to this planet and I start scanning
things you know because I I kind of I
missed the window in no man's sky and
there were so many changes that have
come to know this guy
I was trying to get a No Man's sky in
the past year and it still is just sort
of like a like kind of daunting but also
like vacant sort of experience so I know
people say like there's kind of pot the
point but yeah yeah and I but I guess
that's not the thing I want to want out
of it so like you know uh and I I admit
when I saw in this when they're like
showed mining I was kind of like yeah
when they showed money but then I think
for me where all kind of came around and
came together was the weird and quirky
sort of side stuff and they were teasing
the dude from Oblivion
um some of the other characters that
just kind of popped up and just some of
the things the weird things that you can
do as a player that's what interests me
because I feel like I from Bethesda game
studios at least that was how I loved
playing Skyrim yeah and so we talked
about over there but I was like imagine
being one of the people who crowdfunded
Star Citizen right now and being like we
still don't know have that game and
Bethesda has made the thing that you've
been making for many years already I
must be
annoying as hell but also like the thing
that impressed me most was like it's so
many games so many ideas so many like
systems and all of them look incredibly
polished yeah like in the past you could
watch a Bethesda game trailer and be
like ah that looks rough like the
shooting looks rough you know the
shooting it looked like if you had like
cut the shooting sections out and said
this is the new Call of Duty you'd be
like all right they're doing another
sequel to infinite Warfare or whatever
and it looks on point same with like the
building it that looked like it could
have been I don't know like some Eve
online thing
um and like the mining and destroying
shifts it's hard space ship breaks yeah
you know it was very very comprehensive
it was like sick to see in the combat
like shooting those like ice canisters
and then like jet packing up oh yeah
when they got me it was like oh if you
shoot in zero gravity you can push yeah
and like and I mean you know like I'm
just assuming this because I'll make an
excuse to talk about developer machine
games hey you know I assuming they just
like gave them a call and be like you
can make this feel s good right it
definitely looks like their thing yeah I
I would not be surprised if they were
like oh yeah we had all these people on
it yeah the thing yeah the thing or Ed
yeah the thing that I'm
thinking about now is like
it is space it is it is I think that
of what I want from it I don't know if
I'm gonna get it looks comprehensive it
looks huge it feels like a space life
Sim but is the mystery or like the
Intrigue or the kind of like
the weirdness of space going to be
represented and the game that I think
about that does that incredibly well is
our Wilds like every time you go up into
space
it is like a mind-blowing experience
when you approach a planet like there's
planets in that game that are like
baffling until you spend time on there
and figure out how it works and is that
going to be the case when you approach a
random planet on in Starfield or is
going to be like we've got different
kinds of freaks here and like you know
it's pretty random planet and like also
like we need this kind of stuff done or
is it going to be like I don't
understand how the kind of like
thermodynamics or the gravity of this
planet works I don't understand how to
get around it and then you try and
figure out over and over again and
you're like oh this planet is connected
to that planet over there I need to get
over there I need to slingshot my round
myself around that planet and get like
is that kind of Wonder gonna be there
Beyond you're just going out into a
place and then coming down a new place
and then do the shooting bang bang
whatever it may be I hope that they have
that kind of like
space is dangerous and mysterious and
weird instead of like kind of Frontiers
yeah yeah instead of having like a very
much like a almost like
colonize this [__]
uh overall then let's wrap up uh I
thought I thought it was actually a
pretty good showcase for Xbox I think it
was a really great variety I there was a
lot of stuff in there that took a lot of
boxes for me I'm yeah and I hope that
that's kind of helped change the tide
for like the start of the year that
they've had remains to be seen But like
I just think it was a pretty great
showing I just think it's neat I just
think is it because my voice is gone I
sound like Marge Simpson I just think
it's neat no I thought it was a pretty
good showcase for them I could maybe do
with a little less forts of stuff maybe
a little you know I mean
those games we know are just gonna be
good for the awful I think maybe a lot
like a very specific I think the thing
that I could do without in the forza pot
is where Ford people it's like we have
done that before
that was cool it's like just show the
reasons I know there's people out there
that are like very excited about yeah
Chevrolet or whatever but like is that
this is it is time for you to like plug
a car company yes probably not yeah but
I also think like in terms of the
showing they had
I don't think would have had I mean they
had weird little freaks in them but no
like weird games like unions in new
stuff I don't know there's
um like a really great showing for the
Chinese room I think it was it was great
it kind of got me excited because as
well I think it was pace and obviously
all the stuff was Sega Atlas like it's
really cool to see a Japanese Studio
kind of going all in with Xbox version
you you hit on something there very
briefly that it's worth talking about
which is actually the format of the show
which is something that people pay
attention to a lot more now it's been a
point of discussion for the last few
days weeks months years it's the pacing
of it as you just said like was I think
Immaculate like really well done I
didn't feel bored by how long things are
going or like segments entirely that
felt pointless or Superfluous there were
Parts where I was like this game isn't
for me but I never felt like I'm
disengaging because of the format of
what we got here we saw Phil Spencer
once wearing a hacks and shirt wearing a
hexan shirt which was clearly custom
which is upsetting well he's coming
never wear a t-shirt
unless you're gonna show off a game for
it okay that's what I'm saying
um and and we saw Sarah bonnett's
thought and then Falls man in the middle
three in the world you had the world
premiere voice premiere voice was in
there and it was like paced really well
yep didn't obviously it's welcome up
until the bit where it was an hour long
section on one game that went on and on
but like that is
clearly yeah they put the Starfield
trailer in the main thing yeah yeah okay
that's not yeah that's not it which did
feel but then but then you know when
they said they were doing a deep dive on
Starfield yeah they invented and I and I
feel like you know
like that was the point where if you
felt like I this is too much for me or
you could bounce very easily without
missing anything and getting formal for
it so like props were due on the
construction of that press conference as
far as how it was to experience a press
conference start finish I thought it was
exceptional as far as the content itself
I thought was very good as far as what
it means for the future of Xbox I
thought it was
good could have been better 2024 is
going to be the real you know well and
that but the problem is what you just
said is what a lot of us tend to say
like 2022 it's gonna be the year 20.
it's gonna be my year yes this is my but
I mean no I think I mean for now
Starfield is gonna be yeah I think
that's gonna hold yeah I mean if it
comes out right you know if it comes out
you know you know expectations have been
wonky this year uh but like my thing
with the Showcase is that it was very
balanced it was very clear there was
questions I had going into this that
were answered like it was cool to see a
new a game from compulsions don't know
what it is but I was just cool like okay
good they're doing something I was able
to see a game like a vow that wasn't
just some pre-rendered you know trailer
they shot off like it's it's stuff like
that where I was just like I had
questions I got answers there's like of
course certain things I didn't get to
see and that's fine but I saw Phil
Spencer wearing a hacks and shirt which
always make me be like
if he was wearing a fantasma glory sure
I would have flipped this table I would
have jumped out a window and come right
back up
um
in your in your reality
but I'll wait I was uh again it was one
of those things where I was like uh it
was just good to see a clean concise
well-paced show and
um I had questions that were answered
and like things that like I was
surprised by like Chinese room like
there was very Curt specifications
so I had a good time well thank you
again for joining us on our pre and post
show don't forget we have Phil Spencer
and Matt Busey coming to the Giant Bomb
couch tonight 8pm 8pm uh giantbomb.com
obviously uh and also Twitter TV slash
Giant Bomb I believe we're also gonna be
streaming that to YouTube too so
youtube.com
um we'll also be back again tomorrow
doing post show for the Ubisoft forward
press conference uh I don't know if we
didn't have a Capcom but we will be
streaming everything so uh make sure to
check out on the website because now we
can talk about some of the stuff there's
a more extended chat about the cyberpunk
demo as well as Jake's written thoughts
as well is on there we've got a bunch of
other stuff that we're just about to
film for summer game first uh which will
be very exciting can't wait for you to
see it thank you again for joining us
we'll catch you next time so long